foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
you're never going to beat hikar out his
own game not in these positions within
the Tempest the best have come to test
their skills and brave the storm imagine
down to five seconds gonna move
oh we missed it oh he allowed to drop
for some this is familiar ground
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess
Jagger the moves will be fast oh my God
no 97
tricked at the end the stakes will be
high he just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
I send your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
speed Chess Championship another awesome
match upcoming for us today I'm your
host Grandmaster Daniel nerdinski
alongside me today International Master
David Bruce David you uh very aptly
named us the Sig Club both of us
seriously under the weather today but no
better way to nurse flu covered whatever
we have uh than to watch an awesome SEC
match how are you feeling
yeah I feel I feel great you know if
you're going to be stuck in a room
coughing you might as well have some
chests to watch and uh we couldn't ask
for a more entertaining uh show than the
speed test championships with 16 of the
greatest players in the world playing
tons and tons and tons of Speed games
this is you know a dream come true for
me to be watching this event likewise so
first of all the main question what is
at stake as we review the overall prize
pool it's a cool 100 G's with the winner
earning 2000 and then 2 000 more dollars
split based on win percentage so even if
the match itself the results of the
match is decided there's still plenty of
money to be apportioned based on win
percentage David as if the players need
any more motivation
yeah I did a quick back of the envelope
conversation uh calculation as we were
setting up today and I figured out how
many dollars per hour
the players earn on average during the
speed Chess Championship would you like
to
guess or hear that stat
um I'd guess something like
nice it is more than double that they
earn over 900 an hour across 15 matches
uh that will make up the whole speed
chess championships that's amazing you
heard it here first to 900 an hour on
average as we review the bracket these
players are used to earning big amounts
but all of them are super motivated the
SEC is a marquee event that everybody
looks forward to every year top left
Hikaru Nakamura top right Magnus Carlson
bottom left anishkiri I mean wherever
your eyes go there are amazing names
David
yeah big names all around and that means
also that even in the first round we get
absolutely sick matchups where you see
people who could potentially win the
whole event lose in the first round like
players of that caliber so
um we have a matchup like that today
with um the world championship
Challenger
um yeah nepalmachi going up against the
current reigning world Blitz Champion uh
MBL and I think if either of these
players won the whole speed test
Championship you wouldn't say like that
was impossible
um
so quite a matchup and mvl has won the
speech has championship before he's
defeated Magnus Carlson I think he's the
only player if memory serves me right to
defeat Magnus Carlson in an SEC match
both of them at 32 years old still very
much at the peak of their forms John
napan issue writing an incredible string
of results he leads their overall Blitz
Head to Head nine and a half to six and
a half but in classical mvl leads by a
ridiculously wide margin maybe the the
widest margin David uh of anybody of the
top I mean I don't know anybody to whom
nepo is losing six to one
yeah I can't think of anyone else where
he would have that record right now
um and of course in Blitz that's a much
closer head to head as well as the fact
that their chess.com ratings are right
in line with each other
um so yeah I mean looks pretty close
let's uh let's see what our fans think
is gonna happen in this matchup what the
community predicted between these two
and then well you can say what you think
will really happen well I I Channel what
Robert Hess likes to say which is that
the chess Community is very prone to
recency bias they always go by the last
couple of results and nepo predicted to
win 78 of cases I would predict
something a lot closer to 50 50. I would
still give give you on the edge just
because he's played more recently and he
seems to be in better form in the last
couple of months but the community seems
very very confident that janapanishi is
going to carry this match
yeah I mean recency bias could also mean
just being really attuned to current
form yep but um I made the mistake of
predicting Jan to win the global chess
championships uh because he'd won the
rapid Jazz championships right before
that I got that prediction wrong and uh
I wanted to go against people's
predictions for today so I was gonna
um so I was gonna go for Maxime today
well there's only one way to find out
let's take a look at their chess.com
Blitz insights speaking of more
experience has a lot more total games
ravage accuracy is very similar what's
interesting is that mvl does have a
higher win percentage but again I would
take that with a grain of salt given
that he's played a lot less games
overall is there anything in these
insights that jumps out at you David
yeah I mean I I think uh I think the
average accuracy is important but it's
almost a dead heat I think losses by
flag is important but that's also really
close but you see that he also has mdl
also has an edge and wins by flag as
well as losses by flag and that suggests
to me that he might just be a tad factor
with his Mouse when it comes down to
those final five seconds
um have you watched these two plain
enough to have a sense of who's got the
like last five second Edge I played both
of them a lot on chess.com I I do think
the the statistics bear out the fact
that nepo is a little bit slower I think
I think mvl does benefit in the event of
an all-out time scramble just from
personal experience so for nepo that one
second increment is going to be so
important speaking of the one second
increment before we jump into the games
let's quickly review the format of the
match if you don't know the format where
have you been but if you're just joining
us the SEC is a 16 player knockout uh
knockout means you are are out if you
lose a match players core points across
three time controls five plus one three
plus one and one plus one until time
runs out and in the event of a tie there
are four games of one plus one with
Armageddon bidding and the time control
as I just mentioned 90 minutes
of five plus one it's not a very smooth
delivery 60 Minutes of three plus one
and then 30 minutes of bullet David as
we know it was 30 minutes can and often
are the decisive segment of the match
yeah absolutely that is where you're
most likely to see somebody hit a streak
and win like four games in a row at this
level it's very rare to see a big streak
in the Blitz Games but it is possible in
the bullet game so you can totally flip
a match on its head in bullet
um and you know the decreasing amount of
time per time control allows each of the
segments to weigh sort of similarly in
the final results folks because 90
minutes of five minutes is gonna produce
a similar number of games as 60 Minutes
of three minutes and 30 minutes it's one
minute so the sort of
um your skill across the three time
controls is fairly balanced in the final
results
yeah no that was a very very well put
and the players are getting ready to
kick off the five minute portion once
again we have 90 minutes of five plus
one to be played you can see mvl looking
down there now he looks back up at his
screen
Jana is all smiles well at least the
half of yond that we see
yeah I got goosebumps I'm gonna tell you
Donya when I saw Maxine walk into his
room earlier today I got goosebumps I
was like oh my gosh it is on
you know yeah both look like they're
power Champion walks into a room
that reminds me of the time that I
participated in a Master Class by Gary
Kasparov the first time I ever saw
Kasparov and he walked into the room and
everybody just gasped like that is Gary
Kasparov and everybody's gonna gasp
right now because the match is underway
Jan has the white pieces in game one and
Jan has shown a proclivity for the
Catalan in in recent games let's see
what he brings to the table here
yeah and Maxime has been playing two
openings in general the grunfeld and the
Queen's Gambit accepted with which both
sort of
try to steer clear of uh of the Catalan
so
interesting and anti-grunfeld with E3
trying to limit that Bishop on G7 from
the get-go this is a semi-popular line
it's it's not particularly theoretical
and mvl kind of adjusts his approach uh
going for a benoni setup with C7 C5
maybe trying to exploit the fact that
this Pawn on E3 is blocking in the dark
squared Bishop of course these types of
uh positions one tempo is not decisive
so you often see white going Knight C3
and then pushing E4
yeah that's right there's no reason you
can't uh you can't come around and play
E4
um
let me get them going here all right and
we transposed to a benoni structure
yeah this is just classic benoni
structure the only difference again the
pawn sitting on E3 black could push the
Rook over to E8 to prevent light from
playing E4 instead mvl works on the
queen side A6 obviously before it's
always automatically four totally
automatic you never want to allow B5 in
these positions ever
yeah anybody who doesn't uh who doesn't
know this in chat there's something in
chess called a head Duo which is when
you've got two pawns next to each other
that are somewhat Advanced and uh in an
area that that sort of a pair of Pawns
can just instantly make you really
strong in that area so when black plays
A6 and trying to play B5 Black's looking
to set up a head Duo and uh that's a big
deal if you're able to achieve that
eventually yeah because all the squares
are controlled and then you've got B4
and C4 hovering over you like the sort
of Damocles so A4 is automatic what is
not automatic is a move like H3 instead
white drops the Knight back to D2 and
this is another Super common maneuver in
the benoni the Knight moves into C4 in
order to put pressure on the d61 but
this is where you're really missing your
dark squared Bishop because if the
bishop can come out to F4 then the
pressure on D6 becomes very serious so I
actually think uh Jan might play E4 but
maybe mvl will beat him to the punch and
go Knight B6 to knock the Knight off of
C4
I like black people six is common here
might be safe this is pretty common here
and then uh you know Knight A5 black
probably has Knight B takes D5 in this
particular position but um a lot of
times with the pawn on e4 when black
plays Knight B6 white plays Knight E3
sometimes white plays Knight A3 White's
gonna want to avoid that night trade
whenever black offers it on E5 or B6
yeah 95 Knight E3 you see those moves so
frequently in the benoni I think 95 is
quite likely especially because now that
E4 has finally been played Bishop F4 is
a semi-serious positional threat I mean
if you have to go Knight F6 to E8
um that's that's not the great it's not
the end of the world but especially
because sometimes it can be played
voluntarily to prepare F5
uh but but I'm anticipating 95 here I'm
real taking his time in the early going
is down about a minute but that's
typical Young
yeah I think it's worth checking as
black here whether white can trade on E5
and play F4 and just kind of roll you
instantly with E5
um because of the temping the opening
and white playing E3 and then E4 I would
my instinct would be black can survive
it but I would I would have enough fear
to check that
yeah and VL sinking into a very deep
think here
D5 whoa okay that makes sense
or does it well lots of captures
happening total liquidation oh I think
his idea okay we might see this on the
board so I don't know if it's worth yeah
it's not worth playing on the analysis
board Knight takes D6 David Knight takes
D6 and then Knight B6 and I think mbl's
point is that White's not going to be
able to defend the D5 Pawn I think the
first game is gonna end in a draw
right so after the trades Knight B6 yeah
and Rook d8 um he could either go rook
d8 and take on D5 or he could go Rook A1
looking to just take on D5 from there
right Jan wants none of that because now
Rook A1 is not effective because the
Rook on F1 is protected by the king yeah
so after 1965 1965
mm-hmm
yeah White's generally picking up this
Pawn on C5 even in that like Rook d8
line there would have been Knight p7 to
C5 so he's gonna have to win back the
week B4 Pawn pretty quickly here
yeah and I guess he's gonna do it with
Rook B8
and after Rook be it I think white can't
really defend the pawn Knight D3 Rook B3
Rook D1 White's clinging just Knight
before maybe just Knight before because
of Rook D1 played
confidently carried out by MV on what's
funny David is that if the Knight moves
away from D3 black snack can just drop
back to T5 or he can even pay a visit to
A2
loading up the thread on the bishop as
well as the B2 Pawn so I I really don't
think that nepo has any chances here you
can see the Eva by reflecting that first
game seems to be heading in a peaceful
Direction
so Mike seems stopped and calculated at
a good time right we were thinking of 95
he calculated B5 like eight moves deep
you said well the five minute portion I
can do it I think it's always cute when
the players think for like two minutes
and then they rattle off like nine moves
you know instantly yeah it's always so
funny
that's my dream that's my dream as to
one day be able to think for a minute
and then rattle off nine minutes I
rattle off one move and then my opponent
responds and I'm like oh I missed that
response time for another time for
another nine minute think
yeah that's generally my mistake too I
look nine moves ahead but I overlooked
something I'll move one
John is relevant honest is orchestrating
all sorts of shenanigans to try to keep
that pawn on B2 alive the problem is
that pawn is not going to win the game
unless it eventually ends up on B8 and I
don't think that's happening anytime
soon I would play Knight takes Bishop
here obviously don't take the B2 Pawn
because Rook B1 wins the bishop The Rook
on B5 is undefended so can't quite take
the pawn yes Bishop D4 I think Bishop D4
might be a great move
I also like Rook before
yeah
nepo moves to a but now the Bishop David
is going to move into F6 and just
finally pick up that pawn
yeah it was this that I was slightly
concerned about from Black's perspective
that white could take the bishop off B2
for a second and hold this construction
that's what I wanted to move my Bishop
out of the way from
yep there's that looks like it doesn't
matter
nepo maybe we'll try something like
Knight C5 and try to go 96 but
oh
so I think you should take on B2 with
the bishop so you can meet Knight E6
check with King F6 if you take with the
Rook after 96 King G8 Rook A8 is
checkmate
96 King F6 Knight d8 is uh is a major
worry so
King GA but let's take a minute to
appreciate how nepo has been able to
create chances in this game I thought he
was going to lose the B2 Pawn many moons
ago it's still on the board
yeah
King G8 might have been a brilliant move
he might have needed that move
okay but now Knight D3
Rook B3
and Rook A3 oh oh he's still keeping it
on the board and now it's gonna move to
B4 and then the rook's gonna get behind
it oh this is unbelievable this is
insane to start the match NEPA okay it's
not over yet I mean evl still has good
chances but I think now nepo is it's
like a 50 50 position now he's gonna try
to get his King to C4 yeah there's so
many I mean if you saw the tricks he
pulled out with his pieces on bad
squares imagine now that his pieces are
organized yeah now now he doesn't even
have to worry about his Pawn the problem
for nepo is that the Rook on B5 is so
stable maybe he's trying to get his Rook
to A5 MBL says no no no
foreign
and now he's going to try to get his
King to the queen side again and he does
and he does he's making progress
on the clock and on the board
yeah mpl's short on time to defend this
one it's turned completely epic as
opposed to a simple simplification
now he's allowed beef with a discovered
check
I think mvl is making a desperate dive
toward the king side but he has no pawns
to attack so he goes back Rook D4 he's
just gonna force him back terribly and
now the king defends the pawn which is
the ideal construction Knight C5 check
absolutely hopeless at this point and
MBL hasn't made any blunders he just
made a bunch of inaccuracies to let nepo
keep the pawn Rook B3 allowing Rook A3
that was the big one
so tricky
coming out sharp today
but how is he gonna get the pawn to B6
so you're gonna try to get his Knight
around to C6 it's still not over
and VL has chances here
Rook C2 uh oh
Here Comes The Rook and he's gonna win
but that allows B6
and B7 then black starts grabbing a
bunch of Pawns I don't know maybe give
the bishop up for the pawn if you can
find a way to do that okay maybe throw
in Rook B2 here to get white to play
Rook B5 it seems insane but it avoids
The Rook takes D6 idea later that's a
great point because after Rook takes F2
B7 you can't take another Pawn on H2
due to Rook takes D6 but I think Bishop
B8 there Rook takes F2 and Bishop B8
seems to survive and then maybe Knight
A5 96 and then Friday five Rook back to
B2 20 seconds though can he hold it with
that amount of time
Knight C5 Maybe
ic5 looks very threatening oh my
goodness but that does allow a rook
trade I know what happens in that end
game
I don't think mvl does either
so black needs to like trade upon with
H4 here or the same idea 96 F takes
she's three
yeah 986 fg3 Knight C7 B takes A2 queens
and queens with check and white actually
might lose there because white loses the
Knight
oof
yeah okay that's got one last diagonal
to operate on he's lucky that every
white Pawn was on that diagonal and now
G5 now mvl's desperate window g596 so
basically you have to manage stopping
the b-pawn while without giving up any
King side pawns and he's doing it
perfectly Knight A6 will threaten Knight
C7 but then the king will move back to
d8 to stop it
yeah I'm not sure why the white king
went towards the queen side I would have
wanted my king
for white to like come to F5 or
something well maybe he could now now he
goes back H4 H4 oh and you can't go G3
because that intercepts the bishop and
White's King is now in time to stop the
black pawns and I think winning now
right yeah you just make a queen and
then you easily tame the pawns he wins
yeah
wow what a game
man how many how was that not enough
that one he traded everything off in it
yeah what do you have to do I haven't
quite died
[Laughter]
that was absolutely wild I mean he he
drew that nepo kept the pawn then he
drew again and then nepo kept another
Pawn on the king side unbelievable yeah
okay well that is a very very good sign
for any of nepo's fans or just people
who you know put him in their bracket
because they just thought he was good
even though they didn't like him you
know either way that's a good start for
all of you did you catch that rookie to
rookie one was that a mouse slip or is
that like the New Berlin fashion you
never know these days because now with
these numbers
yeah yeah I've seen Rook E3 to E2 to E1
so I just I don't even know anymore
yeah nowadays
all I know is the black doesn't want to
let white Play Bishop takes D6 and mess
their Pawn structure to heck yeah that's
safe safe to say he moved his Knight to
E4 I can also contribute that white
generally wants to refrain from playing
F3
I like how we're kind of nibbling around
the edges in this position
yeah
Bishop G5
and white goes Queen C1 trying to trade
on his own terms to activate the queen
this is obviously very Josh
yeah I will say
then Maxine's gonna have to bring
something pretty special if he plans to
win the match in the Berlin today
yeah does this constitute something
special no like this kind of position 10
times in a row You're Gonna Lose the
blitz match
unless you're Magnus Carlson I think
well Magnus Carls will be playing the
same position with black it as well as
with white so yeah and win with both
colors yeah but if Maxine's gonna play
you know positions with life with black
and then play positions like this with
white it's not going to be good enough I
like John's last move even though the
evil bar did not Bishop to H4 he's
trying to induce a weakness I guess the
downside is that you've created a fine
keto Square for the white Bishop
and G3 comes with Tempo the bishop G2 is
going to necessitate D5
I don't know if black wants to play that
move and close off his light squirt
Bishop
yeah maybe he's looking at a crazy move
like Knight G5 I think
by by Nature Jan's not a hundred percent
suited to be sort of like a Berlin slash
Petrov player
yeah it is weird
when you see yon wearing those clothes
like the first time he he rolled out the
Petrov in the world championship match I
couldn't believe my eyes because he was
he's like a sicilian lifer
but he's been doing well in it and like
in the Berlin it's rare to play B6 and
Bishop B7 right a little bit yeah I
don't think you see that every day
right like a more normal approach would
be D5 C6 Bishop F5 so Jan chose to play
the position you know just a little bit
more interesting or whatever and now the
bishop on B7 is a little bit weird you
know so I think
I don't know
I definitely white is slightly better
yeah I would feel some more imbalanced
games from from NEPA I feel like he's
constraining himself a little bit when
he when he plays like this yeah for sure
but can mvl squeeze something concrete
out of what is obviously a slightly
better position better Bishop He's Got
The Rook on a good Square he can play
Bishop E5 move like that to try to get
his Rook to a good square but you're not
really going to win the game with you
know these pedestrian moves oftentimes
you see people going H4 in these types
of positions to grab some King side
space I never really know how to squeeze
in these positions but you know the
super GMS do
so let's see what MBL comes up with here
yeah I mean the only idea I see is
Bishop E5 or G5 to trade that bishop and
try and get access to E5 for The Rook
but yeah I don't know if that's enough
yeah I'm the old taking another one of
those vintage long things let's see if
he uncorks another nine move sequence
here somehow I don't think so
yeah I guess if you played rookie two
rookie 8 rookie one just a very simple
doubling black couldn't trade all the
Rooks on E8 because C7 would be hanging
oh that's a good point with the bishop
still yes I guess it was possible to
just start doubling but
let's see now the Rook trades begin
yeah
takes takes rookie eight can he take
with a pawn Maybe
no
and I think so after rookie here I'm
expecting Queen E3
or E2 or E1 I don't care
um I think F4 F6 doesn't do anything
unfortunately I think black's White's
Advantage is fairly nominal
yeah king f8 after Queen E3
yep don't yield the E file without it
being on your own terms I mean you can
take on E5 he goes C4 he tries to spice
things up in the center
well I could meet this with C6
black could also take on E5 first and
then go C6 I actually think that might
make a little bit more sense
and I don't see how white puts pressure
on that D5 funner puts pressure at all
in that resulting position the Evo bar
is still giving a slight advantage to
white though
oh really okay yeah yeah I've been I've
been expecting that whenever white
played C4 black could play C6 and then I
didn't see any further and so I didn't
know whether or not to play C4
yeah nepo obviously deciding between the
immediate C6 or trading on E5 first
which changes the structure it gives
white the default also gives white and
palm Jordan he does neither he goes H6
what most unexpected move what if C
takes D5
yeah what is the bishop takes D5 or what
is the idea
I I I don't know
and I don't know neither is mvl I guess
we're about to find out Rook d8
so he gives up the e-file
but how is he gonna win this Pawn back
like what if I just goes Queen E3 for
example
yeah this looks really bad to me Tanya
um yeah weird
like no matter how weak D5 is it's very
hard to cash it in without dropping A7
or C7 or the seventh rank on E7 which
isn't a pawn but still something yes he
stops king f8 queen E3 King f8 so he
goes to B4 he goes to B I thought he
might go Queen E1 with the idea Leading
The Rook space and king f8 queen B4
pretty good straight to B4 that would
have been cool actually
I guess this does allow The Rook to
return to E8 and it does yeah
now it would be premature
well actually maybe not to take and go
D6
no I guess it doesn't work because after
Bishop takes G2 King takes G2
there is the move Queen C6 check
forking the king and the oh
I don't know who that is for King The
King and the D6 spawn
I'm not opening the door
um I think this is good I think this is
good for black I'm not expecting anybody
it's not me so
I'm gonna check my phone but I'm
definitely not expecting anybody
yeah
I guess Queen C4 would be one move here
okay he plays to B3
oh hits two spots at once now on A3 A7
and rookie seven threatened
and uh I'm feeling very good here if I'm
MPL
very good I mean I don't know why my
opponent let me take on D5 but
you know we don't look gift pods in the
mouth right we take it we
yeah I mean rookie seven you don't
necessarily want to rush because then
the queen moves into F5 and then you
potentially allow a check on B1
so F5 Rooks I love that movie I mean
it's so such a grand master move you
know just keep the tension
oh but look it was our one chance to
play Rook E7 if we really wanted to play
it
yeah D6
Bishop takes you to what's going on Rook
takes C8 oh in blunder's the queen C6
move
oh what did he just do he did
the wrong order
she did it in the wrong order
yeah
I mean you only get so many chances to
get into the seventh rank no but all you
had to do let me rewind for a second as
king takes usually bring up the analysis
board real quick because the game's
gonna end in a draw now
after King takes G2 white keeps the
extra Pawn because if black takes then
the pawns defend each other Queen C6
check here is no longer effective
actually white has the move D5 winning
on the spot and finally if C takes D6
and the queen is overextended and this
is great winning chances for white you
know this is a 50 50 position
but Emeril Cannell can't afford these
types of slips if he wants to be nappy I
mean you just left that completely on
the table
yeah
that was unfortunate now
I mean
now he has to be careful
in this position here
because he's lower on time I think you
know a minute and a half down
it's just got to be a bit careful here
yeah
nepo's looking to try and you know make
some kind of little Advantage here
G5 pushing the pawn
looking to pass an H Pawn and make
threats against White's King and then
when necessary he can win the defense
better now
yeah I mean he's looking at H4 Queen G5
H3 Queen H6 and it doesn't work out not
yet he defends his Pawn 13 seconds for
mvl is nepo doing it again the second
game in a row the shenanigans start
King D5 tightening the screws
now if the queen can get to G3 that's
going to be something
yeah just calmly defends his sea Pond
beautiful move lots of pressure on white
here unfortunately with five seconds
left so easy to blunder upon one second
Queen E2 he gives up the D4 Pawn oh my
goodness oh he just collapsed I think he
wants queen F2 Queen takes B6 but then
he's gonna give up F3
oh yeah
give me five zigzagging his way back to
safety
or is he yeah
maybe King E6 yeah
oh
perpetual
oh you allowed Perpetual when the black
king goes to A6 is it Queen C8
King A6 Queen C8 you can the A4 pawn
stops the king's escape to B5 which is
maybe what nepo missed
and mvl escapes with a draw
first time he had to show that strength
in the last five seconds that we talked
about and he had it
yeah I mean it puts you in a defensive
I was gonna say it puts you in kind of a
defensive frame of mind right when it's
like the game you're supposed to win
back and then you have to have that few
feeling like you dodged a bullet
yourself
yeah it's crazy that they even reached
that position mvl
could have lost that if nepo maybe had
chosen a different path with this King
if he'd stayed in the center but it
wasn't easy to win that obviously so a
draw isn't a bad result All Things
Considered but allowing Queen C6 check
their Fram veal
was that big blunder which led to
the subsequent near disaster they were
repeating the opening from game one
David I don't remember if they had this
exact position I think they had it with
the inclusion of a6a4
mm-hmm yeah 26 A4 Bishop G4
chat a little bit mad Donya that that
nepo didn't use his extra minute to be
more careful about his extra Pawn that
he had there uh how do you feel about
that well it's nepo I mean he he airs on
the side of being of being fast
and sometimes that cost him I think it's
costing him in this game as well he's
off to a really bad start in this game
he's allowed B5 oh yeah here this is
your thing calculation is Knight takes
D6
85. yeah I don't know if he
I don't know if he calculated something
and and in one second and now he's doing
like the 10 second double check but um
and he plays it
yeah but does it solve his problems I
still like Black's position
that pawn on D5 is kind of both the
strength and a weakness
Knight to E4 hitting the bishop hitting
the pawn it's a spot
finds a spot
reaction
I mean yeah D6 96 that Knight's gonna be
really well placed and that's what nepo
thought as well he's trying to bail this
game out but after Rook E8 black is
going to be threatening to take on C5
because the queen has been he plays it
so Rook C1
AAC one get off the diagonal that Bishop
it's an angry Bishop you always want to
clear off The benoni Bishop's diagonal
that trains train sound came from you
right
that's right okay that's right by the
train tracks
I didn't think I had any train stations
near near where I live but maybe I'm
wrong
yeah I like that sound actually
yeah I know we've got an active well
here it's uh it's pretty exciting
Knight to E6
by mvl obviously black is the only one
who could be better here has got more
space better Bishop
but if nepo handles this carefully he
should be able to hold this oh the
problem is maybe on that Rook ac1 move I
wanted to play that the black queen
could do an A2 did he just blunder that
pawn
and now he's allowed it that that's
White's issue right it's like your B2
Pawn is sensitive but how do you play
Rook A1 without hanging your a pawn
perhaps the answer would have been well
how about moving the other Rook or A3
or move the other Rook let's say to D1 I
mean not sure other Rook you can move
the other Rook I'm just saying you've
got this lasting problem that that as
long as your Rooks on A1 and your pawns
on B2 you're under some pressure
yeah I mean I'm I'm still I just can't
believe nepo gave up a pawn in one move
and now we started thinking
maybe another way out would have been
Queen B3
because it trades trades Bishop B2 you
have Rook a seven let me show that line
on the announce word that's a cool idea
Queen B3
Queen takes B3 a b
and then the pawn on A7 is now hanging
Bishop takes B2 you can take on A7 and
this is probably closer to a draw than
anything else anyways right they've made
a bunch of moves they're in an end game
now
and this is a winning end game for black
you know why because this bishop on G7
controls the promotion score it's the
worst case scenario for white
now I bet you that mvl has won this
position here a hundred times out of the
gruenfeld
he's like when I when my a pawn gets
loose like it is over
and uh I think you just plop the bishop
on B2 Pawn on A3 trap a rook
and then uh Play The King side
yeah Bishop b2a3 rook ec8 and Rook C3
lots of ways lots of roads lead to Lyon
he is the Leon Beast after all correct
absolutely correct yeah
okay so playing this way gives him the
option of maybe putting a rook on B2 at
some point
um
yeah I mean the the most annoying thing
is that black can basically just chill
for as long as he wants he's not losing
that A3 Pawn even if white plays Rook
fa1 and Bishop C1 just logistically very
difficult because they're allowing a
back ring mate
black can put his Rook also on the third
rank
and he can like bring his King to the
center he can go F5 and expand on the
king side that's why these positions are
so hard to say because you can torture
forever
mm-hmm
yeah oh
okay well the idea move no no no no no
no that's the move you play when you
have the advantage and you're trying to
keep your opponent from setting up F7 G6
H5
you don't play G4 when you're trying to
defend your king side that's not a thing
yeah he's creating another weakness
I feel like nepo's gone off the rails
this game but it's it we've seen him
hold these types of positions
good from here it's going to be looking
at H3 because eventually nepo is going
to have to play H3 to defend this pawn
and he's also preventing F3 by
pressuring that Bishop look at the
clocks by the way two minutes extra
you would think nepo is the one playing
black but no this time it's mvl
yeah
Rook C8 activating his other Rook he
might play F5 carving out a path for his
King but the downside of that is that it
trades off this potentially weak Pawn on
G4 it's not such a weak Pawn now that
it's been defended
yeah how do you win this exactly I would
want to poke at it with H5
but I was thinking to uh put a rook on
the fifth rank like Rook D5 instead of
Rook C8
yep
King F3 is chat saying funny things
Donya shat is always saying funny things
nice when is shot not
you know bringing us Pearls of Wisdom
okay so here he's got the idea like King
G6 Rook G1 check
it was Bishop G7 kind of an attack oh
if rookie two
and I think black's gonna put that Rook
on A8 and he would have put the B3 Rook
on B2 he goes Rook G1 he actually moves
away from the a file
yeah I knew he was dreaming of a
counter-attack here I always knew it
nepo's always looking for ways to get
his opponent's king doesn't matter if
you're in an end game there he goes
again yep Rook D5 now he's attacking H5
and the g file is open
yes yeah
has mvl messed this up again
I don't believe so I think it's actually
getting easier and easier for black to
win like this
um I don't know
what do you do though how do you defend
this H fund first order of business I
don't think you can you can play Rook H6
I mean I'm thinking
goes Rook F6 the king moves up to E4
I want to somehow just play Rook G6 and
A2
oh Rook G6 does look very juicy here
but then I'll take on H5 take on G6 and
move back to A5
right that's what I couldn't arrange the
timing the way I thought I could you
really wish your king was on G8 here
then Rook G6 I think would just win
instantly
yeah I don't know what to do here with
black
oh man okay A Move ago instead of Rook
F6 check maybe A2 Rook takes H5 check
Rook H6
oh
so it's possible again in this position
A2
A2 here let's pull up an analysis board
real fast A2
Rook takes H5 check Rook H6
yeah what an idea and if you take on H6
obviously you can't take with the bishop
here black wins okay one Rook A3 and
then the next move Bishop G7 to dislike
come back exactly apparently there's the
crazy resource here Rook takes G7 I plan
for that and Rook A5
potentially a fortress I don't know it's
a 50 50 position
but they've gone down a different route
he gives up the H Pawn
finally
to prevent Rook A5 he says we don't need
the H1 to win the game but Rook A5 is
White's main drawing resource great idea
by mvl I think this this might be the
game-winning idea
so it's too late to go back to A1
because it wrote D6 check
um if white goes after the G7 Bishop
with moves like Rook G5 then just Rook
G6
and there will be no happiness there
no should D4 loses to Rook D4 Rook G6 oh
good good point winning The Rook on G1
so he's low on options here there's
always like the exchange sack on G7 but
without Rook A5 The Rook on H5 can't get
back and set up a defense yeah I mean
you would only exchange that gear if you
you were assured to win the a pawn and
here you can't do it I think nepo is
yeah he's running out on the clock he
goes Rook G4
still trying for Rook A5 yeah so okay
or A2 because Rook A5 there's Rook D6
check
all over
it's got it nice comeback win by mvl it
was in question at some point but the
opening I mean nepo never recovered from
that opening
yeah no he ended up like everything
liquidating and then the G7 Bishop just
put him under pressure and sort of like
a simple technical way but uh he gave up
a pawn very quickly and was never
anywhere near defending it that's NEPA
always like half smiling
[Laughter]
always has this like semi-grin on his
face
he's a professional chess player I guess
there's kind of two ways that can go one
you can be like uh Richard Rapport and
just be like oh misery oh whoa like what
was me yeah right or you could be like
dude I sit around playing games all day
and I'm getting like paid to just have
fun
yep
that's a good way of putting it and
they're getting paid to repeat the same
Berlin line this time with Bishop G2
boo yeah lots of Trades you sort of
saved a Tempo on Bishop G5 not that it
seemed too significant but come on guys
is this is this all that you can do out
of the opening
not really
but here's one thing they have done for
us Donya they gave us a win for black in
game three yesterday's match we waited
two hours for black to win their first
game every single game it was like very
very safe openings from White putting
lots of pressure on black
very very serious I will admit I I
didn't I was going to watch but I I was
so fevered I couldn't even hold my phone
up so I was like passed out all day so I
didn't I will watch it after after the
commentary today
yeah yeah just to say there's like there
is a little bit of of spice here a
little bit of wildness
um just off these uh off these games
where an apple is white already so
yeah and yes ding did win yesterday ding
yeah that I knew ding wins I mean again
counteracting the sort of narrative
there's these players that people think
yeah they're not as good at rapid and
Blitz doing carowanas in that club and
they're constantly disproving those
narrative Fabby wins round one against
none other than our generic I see ding
yeah it's another strong opponent and
Sasha grishook
so this SCC is like the NBA season this
year lots of good teams
okay Knight h24 yeah I mean why does
white is a pull here and the Knight is
slightly better than the bishop because
the positions close but like how are you
actually going to win how are you going
to produce chances everything's defended
a million times
right
congrats I think I think you've trade
all the Rooks and then you play for a
million moves with the queen at night
exactly and then you call over if you
can get
see if you can get get a little fork or
something somewhere working some
weaknesses you know maybe some A4
here okay I'll play H6
you guarantee A4 for one here I
guarantee you that move will be played
at some point slightly annoying
oh at some point yeah I know these guys
okay you don't play on Flink
he's done his job on G4 is he going to
F5 and what is he going to be doing
there well it's going to be threatening
Queen G4 that's a construction worth
remembering by the way people
H5
beautiful idea
Bishop takes G3 of Queen H5
on enough to overloaded
F takes G3 Rook takes C3 and here of
course black is already better
yeah and if white would have played
Knight F5 then black will have G6 the
GeForce square is under control
and here you merely get yourself trapped
so astute
defensive mindset for Yan and I think he
saw that I would say setting up F7
I would say setting up F7 G6 H5 is like
great for black
King G2
King G7 I like I'll have what she's
having
and the center has opened up the Knight
on D5 looks imposing David but it can be
kicked off pretty easily with Rook D6
foreign
what do we say about this position draw
yeah
yeah without being supported that night
is nothing special I would even go Rook
D6 right now just get the night off of
the
the square forces back to the three
forces back to F4 and if it goes back to
F4 I would just trade it enough for a
draw
yeah I mean there's not much to say in
this type of position no targets at all
Center is a non-existent
yeah they have the same thinking pose by
the way if you look over at their
cameras yeah
yeah I I would also be be ready to call
the game a draw if it were me
but then again with Jan you never know
he just whips up chances out of nowhere
and he is up on time
ooh Rook C7 a little spice here
but if the Knight drops back to F4 I
think we're gonna get a trade now it
goes back to E3
and will it jump into oh wait The Rook
is hanging
so Knight C4 Rook takes F2 wins upon
I think Rook C2 is forced
or am I missing something
yeah I guess Rook C2 it's on the board
um we might get a rook trade
and that basically means a draw
if the Rooks are off the board
then I think there's virtually nothing
left to play for
broke back to D4 Napo trying to keep the
Rooks on the board and then VL is
pursuing him with Rook C4 it's hard to
say who's playing for a win in this type
of position largely because it's so
equal nobody is yeah no because nobody
is
yeah how about trade and queen D5 here
ooh
I like it and then I'll play Queen F6
and pretend to pretend to play for a win
yeah it's like I'm just in the camp
where I'd be so ready to be done with
this game if you go Queen F6 after the
trade I could take the B Pawn no
oh yeah that's true and then maybe I
could have won back the pawn with Queen
B2 later but this reminds me don't draw
the game with Queen B2 this type of game
reminds me of when I would get a draw
for when I was really young from a high
rated player
and I knew immediately that I would
accept the draw because I already felt
that
you know that rush but I knew my coach
today had angry at me so what I would do
is the classic technique I would take
the rest of my time and I would pretend
to be thinking about it and then I'd say
well I was low on time anyway so you
know I had to take the draw except I it
was never like actually a decision
right
yeah I
um
do you think either of them thinks that
they're trying to win this game or
what's what's um
what's holding them to this position
because I could have agreed to a draw
three minutes ago and I'm not a very
dryish player
yeah
no I I'm not sure
Knight F4 although black is kind of
surrounding White's Pawns
yeah but white please take my opponent
on A2 please
Bishop F6
Knight back to F4 and we might get a
repetition here
no
not a chance to based on the queen side
Bishop B4 is Yan now trying
is Yan now trying
I think so I think he's trying
so he wants to get his Pawn all the way
to A3 maybe and play Bishop B2 to cut
off the defense of that pawn
yeah and again let's not forget mvl is
down to 30 seconds this has kind of been
an early narrative I mean mvl has been
down on the clock more often than not
although in the previous game it was the
exact opposite
but Queen C7 threatens 96 so don't fall
asleep on White's attacking chances
either
right this has gotten spicy all of a
sudden out of nowhere
the queen doesn't have a simple way to
re-centralize herself on A3 she's nope
excited about what she's doing but
but she's abandoned her husband on G7
yeah
wait how does black defend against 96
exactly so
let's bring up an analysis word eight
takes B3 is is the kind of a lot of
people wouldn't play just c96 check and
you say oh this doesn't work but if you
keep calculating after King F6 Knight
takes D4 B takes A2 the king is it's not
that safe but it can't be checkmated it
can always duck back to G7
and here I think black is the only one
with chances although Knight C2 should
you know you maybe not anyways white can
also try
after King F's or White can also play a
takes B3 but then Queen takes B3 defends
the E6 Square exactly that's the only
way back so okay Bishop A1 he's allowed
96 while hiding the king wait apparently
white is Checkmate Queen d8 Knight G5 oh
and Queen no
sevens
Queen t7 because you can't play Queen no
way back no we have made 96 is a fork so
he's got to go King H6 and now he gets
mated with Queen G8 Jan is lost
okay we need to I I'll show the the line
with with King uh G7
for the folks who might have missed it
as the Mexican gets underway
so that what he missed here was that
after King G7 white plays the simple
Queen D7
and he was relying on Queen fa looks
safe right no 96 Fork
goodbye hp3 I'm not taking back I'm
taking on F7 with mate
can you believe that
okay well and the ends of the 90s fans
of the 90s are gonna love this we've got
some throwback Theory here
yeah this is like Valeri salov against
yes yeah
before Casper Shadow banned him from
Elite chess yeah called him a chess
tourist
God these are old people references
David
the chat is like what are they talking
about yeah nobody in chat knows gusalem
is yeah is Maybe
yeah
fun factuality is fluent in Russian and
in Chinese
anyways
so the top Grandmasters in the world in
the 1990s so they're playing at grunfels
kind of a classic grunfelt position
right if if you had to do a Pictionary
entry for the grinfeld I would just give
this position
that would that would work for sure
now it's going to be that D5 Pawn
against that a pawn
don't get your queen trapped don't
collect 200 don't give up E7
but maybe you do give up B7 and just
drive this Pawn down and close your eyes
that is that is how it works sometimes
it's like self-driving a pawn hope it
doesn't explode just start pushing it
King G2 oh the F Pawn was saying I
didn't see that
oh me neither me neither yeah oh clever
he's defending E7 while controlling the
D6 Square he didn't expect that he was
also attacking F3
gets out from behind his own iPod
I don't I'm surprised by that as well
because now white can have a Pawn on a
rook on A7 in these positions absolutely
but don't take on E7 Queen G5 I mean
look at mvl such a devilish little move
basically he's playing for the Perpetual
check here like he could even go
F6 completely killing his own King what
a good idea of Queen E7 Queen G5 this is
Worth showing on on the analysis word F6
now the reason it doesn't work I think
David is because yeah Queen E7 Queen G5
is a draw because if you try to run this
way the queen pursues the king vs C1 if
you go King H1 same thing Queen C1 if
you go King H3 Queen H5 so everywhere
you go there's a drop at Queen G3 I
think
at a minimum is winning or queen E6
check and Rook takes E7 to cover the
check with Queen G4 oh and the Queen's
still on the
on the diagonal yeah yeah and apparently
the email bar was showing and even more
convincing one but anyways but now he's
in serious trouble after Rook A7 right
like I wanted to play Rook A8 and queen
G5 at once but you can't do both and now
oh yeah it looks tough
yeah he's gonna lose upon it's going to
be a five on four
I mean obviously this is a draw with
best defense no no doubt about that
okay he goes he goes passive we'll see
if that's enough my first instinct was
to sort of rush the king to E5 and see
if we could
engineer Pawn trades with F5 and E6 but
mm-hmm
see how this works maybe why does the
one who wants to engineer upon trade to
yeah now I think NEPA wants to play like
F4 and then F4 F5 with the second F Pawn
and turn the H Pawn into a passer
take your pawns to the orthodontist
it's breaking them out
or just get them pulled you're like
there's nothing we can do about this
Pawn on F2 let's pull it yeah maybe your
opponent wants to see who play out for
it's the equivalent of the pawns getting
Invisalign
okay King F7 asking nepo politely how he
intends to make progress
is that rook and A3 stops H4 from being
possible
yeah the plan I see right now is to
defend F2 with your own Rook like take
the Rook to the second rank move the
king up to G4
and maybe plan from there you know
what's funny when you're time scrambling
you know when you play like Rook A1 Rook
V3 Rook soon try to get your opponent to
pre-move onto the same file here
obviously they have both of three
minutes
yeah
plus I've never done that
oh there's The Rook on the second rank
in the G4
that's mate
okay
just pointing that out luckily my plan
is off four
somebody else
sorry to hear that that was me a year
ago
um
not pleasant
yeah no anytime you get your body taken
apart it uh it hurts
Rook C1 played and F I didn't think that
this would prevent F4 so yeah F4 gets
played rookie one oh the idea is if F3
then Rogue G1 check dislodging the king
and winning the F Pawn
yeah and you're stuck with your King on
the H file and you have to worry about
losing oh and what makes things even
worse is that after King F3 black pushes
G4
forcing the king back then you take on
e4 severing the connection between the
pawns and then you're gonna win D5
this was a precise move this kind of
kills it
I mean this is maybe fg5 rookie 4 check
agree to a draw territory
yeah and that's why the email bar is
showing zeros alternatively Rook B4
okay
then well I can't get fancy with rookie4
um
they could just train on
okay
he's gonna play G4 check and then go
after the H Pawn maybe no
MPL gets the original trade but it's
still rookie too is the idea still Rook
G2 is the idea
yeah is the idea and D6 is the idea for
white mode don't keep your King on F7
it's never too late to blunder
Never Too Late yeah I would have been
like I've got that I've got that F Pawn
let me play my G5 move
all right well done by the two players
yeah solid clean game
well that's got to be encouraging for
Maxime I would say like if you can trade
into that worse end game with White's
Rook you know patrolling E7 and A5 and
then just draw it just fine gives you a
shot of confidence that your end games
are all right today
yeah I think I think both players forums
are decent in the early going of this
match I mean Jan
making some sloppy moves here and there
but this just has the the aura of a
close match you just get the feeling
that they're going to go back and forth
the entire way because they're just
watch me move to me what's the idea
after Rook F3
I was just going to advise chat like
it's fine to play Passive moves like
King F2 or King E2 if you always go
forward
well he has to repeat yeah actually and
he's lucky he has this repetition or
he'd lose a pawn
you're right it was a sloppy move
and there we go ladies and gentlemen the
score stands at two for Yana palmushi
three for the Frenchman with three names
he leads by one here alongside I Am
David pruce David
your quick thoughts on the match so far
before we go on a break
well I decided to uh throw my luck in
with the uh with the blue with the
French today and uh I think uh We've
surprised 78 of uh of the
prognosticators with a small Maxime lead
so far and uh things are looking pretty
exciting they are indeed the five-minute
segment will continue but first a short
break we'll be back with more SEC
coverage very shortly
thank you
chest kick is fun for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent-approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Championship observing a lovely match
between janapanushi the world
championship Challenger and mvl Maxine
Michelle agrov alongside I Am David
Bruce David we could not ask for a
closer more entertaining match thus
farther halfway through uh halfway and
change through the five plus one portion
and we've got 40 more minutes of five
plus one action as we take a quick look
at Jan's match-up card
yeah
um Insight strength applying pressure is
that um is that putting uh
getting an advantage or getting mistakes
out of the opponent
either way makes sense for him
I think it's just being gone upon you
see like Being John Malkovich being on
the palm Nutri
yeah he just his very essence is
exerting pressure well let's see if we
can exert some more pressure here to tie
up the match because he's down one he
has the black pieces and another Berlin
and another Berlin
another Berlin and another rookie one
we're gonna see that Rook traveling back
to E2 again
very shortly
or is he on gonna deviate
well Maxine just deviated with Knight C3
um in the past he's so far today he's
played D4
oh
um true
yeah when he plays Knight C3
yeah this is super popular Bishop C7
Knight F5 and white goes after the
bishop pair in this line normally yeah
but yeah I'm taking a little time here
now he goes Bishop C7 and now Knight F5
as far as I know is the move
yeah there's also C4 I think
um in order to trade once on D5 when
black plays D5 and uh he's Mutual iqps
definitely also a move
grabs the bishop pair and now I know
there's there's D3
yep D3 is played
and often white tries to play G3 and
this move F5 it appeared on the scene I
think a couple years ago as an antidote
to G3 wanna now meet G3 with F4 so white
has to find alternate arrangements for
his light skirt Bishop
yeah but that Bishop was definitely
destined for for G2 so Mike seems gonna
have to play it slower
I mean you can still play G3 you just
have to have something in mining and
step four
yeah
I expect we'll see like Bishop D2 from
him before he does anything
more decisive just improving that
coordination a little bit yeah same type
of idea Bishop F4
an instructive positional mistake would
be to go D4 allowing the Knight to jump
into E4 if Queen takes that five is bad
for the same reason 94. mm-hmm at least
I think maybe it's not so clear but I
don't think he's going to go upon
grabbing here
yeah I would be looking at rookie six as
white here looking to double up Rooks if
black opposes us on E8 we'll be able to
grab the F5 Pawn
juicy Square
nice good call comes in he comes in
against Queen B6 I think we have B3 but
that's the thing white has to look out
for as we're kind of abandoning the
whole Queen side and hoping that the
e-file
has something going on yeah compensates
for it in some way
does black need to play G6 at some point
like what how would you handle this F
Pawn which is looking kind of like a
slight weakness just dangling out there
it's one of those situations where you
look at the Evo bar and it's giving 0.3
and you think yeah it's not a big deal
but practically speaking it's quite an
unpleasant position from like very easy
to go down a pawn here what I'm looking
at is Queen D7 Rook 81 and then rookie
eight but Jan he goes for your path he
goes G6 okay I would be very reticence
to play that Queen E3 yeah I hear Queen
E3 to D4 is kind of my
my my fear
he doubles what's first
and Yan holds it together you know
what's funny if he played the other Rook
to E8 white could have taken the Knight
and he played Rook C to E8 white can
take the Knight on F6 but if you play
Rook fe8 white can't take the Knight on
F6 that's a great counter-intuitive and
Jan potentially blundering another Pawn
now he's thinking because after Rook
takes C8 let's bring up an analysis
board all of a sudden the least likely
Pawn to lose the A7 Pawn right as far
away from the war zone as possible
that's the pawn you actually end up
losing because of the fork
and it's just a pure Pawn down end game
but the problem is that if you take back
with the Knight yeah you avoid losing a
pawn but now you give up complete
Monopoly over the E file so I mean both
options look equally unappealing here
yeah yeah yeah it looks uh it looks
terrible I would my first instinct is
I'd rather be down upon than be this
abject
on the e-file
yeah he's super constrained and now he
does cling to his pawn it would be weird
to give up yeah both
oh I was thinking before but there is
Queen G7 saving black there I was
thinking Queen D4 arranging The Rook on
E6
I would consider the move C4 to try to
open up a front in the center
C4 and H4 are going to be candidate
moves maybe Queenie six like sometimes
you creep in oh but you got it done yes
C4
yeah it just looks like a leverage takes
a page out of yawn's strengths applying
pressure and what you're ultimately
trying to do in the event of DC DC is
you want to go C5 and open up a diag for
the bishop to restrict Black's king and
you could get checkmated really easily
with uh collinear pieces you know the
bishop controlling one diagonal and the
queen controlling the other it's a
classic mating pattern
and a classic word code linear it's my
first time hearing it on a chess
broadcast
I like to throw those out once in a
while well a collinear move is actually
a term in chess I think
I I believe you I just have never heard
it described like that before well yeah
does Queen D4 do anything here I think
I'll say the same question as I do
Queen just the same questions
John is holding for now
so energy seven I'm thinking rookie six
Rook f8
um
right and then Queenie five
he goes King G7 oh he's playing rookies
rookie eight
the goalkeeper comes out
yeah
yeah this might be a moment to trade on
D5
go from YouTube isolated pawns and maybe
you were revert to the old idea and go
G3 Bishop G2 just saying hey I don't
only need to attack the king I can also
attack your weakness on D5
yeah
just given F1 something to do because
we've got a great position even without
Bishop F1 like it's doing absolutely
nothing yeah it's weird you've got a
piece that's not playing
yeah and I figure on TD5 if black does
anything fancy like Rook d8 or queen D6
that Rook E6 would be good for white so
it looks like Gianna is more or less
stabilizing because if you go Queen E5
which is a very tempting move then
rookie 8 forces The Rook trade and I
think black keeps all of his pawns
intact because you can always cover a
check on C7 with Queen F7 or even Queen
D7
yeah so I think he's going to trade on
D5 now and then put the Rook on B6 or
something
yeah
um but yeah I mean I I thought clearly
that Jan had prepared this this rookie 8
resource here so
mbl's gonna have to find some other
juice here he's not just going to be
able to put two pieces on the file and
win
unfortunately for mvl not and and Jana
has kept the time Advantage again
so he's done
he's done a good job here CD is on the
board so now he decides to take that
does give up the C file though
no Rook d8
if you tries to do something fancy as
you predicted
whoa King hides out on H6
John was ready
but there's no right back
yeah there's he's lost control of E8
he's locked controlled F6 and his King's
out there so
while there's no immediate tactical shot
for white after King H6 there's no
immediate way for both to heal their
position
Rook D7 to E7
uh-huh that's a good defensive maneuver
Rook D7 maybe I'll throw in Bishop G2
Bishop G2 is going to disorganize him
yeah because then rookie seven Bishop
takes D5 wins the piece
I think Bishop G2 is strong here
yeah
but apparently the evil bar didn't like
it
it's it's four I just didn't like it
Knight C7 maybe the white Rook actually
doesn't have a lot of good squares
maybe Knight C7 is the reason and queen
E3 check F4
oh that's a nasty line
one must be careful
yeah I'm taking his time here he senses
that he needs to react very accurately
in this position
back to C70 goes and The Rook on E6
has to shift to F6 and now White's given
up the E file and is white Now worse
looks slightly worse isolated Pawn oh
oh King G7 white loses he loses is this
Rook trapped is that it well it keeps
his head angrily that's it yes and if
the queen moves back to H3 then black
takes the Rook with his King to keep the
black Rook protected no way no way out
mvl has lost control of the game
that's crazy because yeah black wasn't
even threatening to take the Rook black
was threatening to take the queen
wow that turned around so quickly the
moment he gave up the e-file the game
ended
man that was tricky of beyond that five
they've got the wrong colors here and uh
they were boarding twice in a row
should be on with white now
we've got the wrong colors again okay
running three times in a row
um
all right
we're waiting for the appropriate colors
to be assigned
yeah loves this kind of stuff
anything that shows like some of the
the postmodern modern absurdity of our
existence exactly
nice little Spice in the middle of some
chess the clock match clock continues to
tick
not exactly sure
you know what the issue is
yeah and they are liking it too I think
like chess.com has just deciding there
we go Jan's had too many whites over the
course of his career he's he's too
dangerous with the initiative and yeah
we have to start controlling that and
giving us thank God for white the gods
are just loving it he's just he is
loving King's Gambit okay
let's go all right you like that what
Bishop D7
is that a bad move
I've seen no move other than C6 in a
long time in that position normally
black just plays C6 Pawn takes C6 Knight
takes C6 very very simple not Tempo
looking move and the point is the bishop
on B5 is vulnerable to Queen B6 check if
you castle and to Queen A5 check if you
play D4 first and so
um that position has been considered
fine for black for a million years yeah
literally a million years since the time
of steinits
same thing
world champions whose names begin with S
yeah but listen
yeah white slightly better now he's got
the normal King's Gambit Advantage this
is like the standard small Edge for the
king's Gambit is just the D4 Pawn
against the F7 Pawn little space in the
center
um both yawn and Magnus have played the
king's Gambit a couple times and shown
that they know how to handle this
particular positional Advantage I think
Magnus beat Wong yuei with this position
and uh and Jan's played it several times
and what's interesting is that a lot of
casual chess fans when they think of the
king's gamut they think of like refuted
openings and what they often don't
understand is that it's Kings game has
not been refuted I think refuted in the
modern sense basically just means that
there's like 17 different lines that
equalize so the opening is can no longer
considered that challenging but it's not
like black has a single line that is
generally considered to lead to a big
Advantage none that has not been found
against the king's Gambit
yeah I mean it and it looks like Maxim's
Bishop D7 instead of C6 as I mentioned
earlier it doesn't look like this is
going to be something that anyone would
ever repeat
because as black you don't want to give
white the advantage in the king's Gambit
you don't need to give white an edge
no most certainly not I mean I think
we shouldn't overstate the case black is
very solid here
but totally playable but D5 is is a
pretty nasty Prospect if white pushes D5
he's got that Rook on D1 x-raying the
queen black can get pushed around
something fierce in the center
yeah and I would have played Rook 81
from the get-go in this position I would
have never put the Rook on the e-file I
would have immediately put it to D1
immediately push for D5
there we go
buckle your seat belts d5's on the board
yeah if this came out of another opening
you know people would consider Black's
position satisfactory but coming from
the king's Gambit black doesn't need to
suffer
yeah it's like benoni 0.6 is like
basically black is winning
Ry Lopez points same evaluation
it's considered an abject failure so it
all depends on the opening and what your
expectations are from that opening
yeah
now Maxine is playing very actively this
Knight on on F4 maybe fishing for some
tactics like Knight takes G2 at some
point
[Music]
um
you know and then Queen G4 Knight F4
kind of follow-up
goes G3 another one of those fancy moves
Frozen G3
yeah he's always ready he's always
seeing that trick you know you play like
the moves that would cause me to be
surprised from the opponent he's always
seen it coming
and now he takes the bishop on G1 so
White's biggest asset is this Knight on
D5 Jan might take back with with the
Knight I mean he only has two options I
don't think he's gonna go taking that
Bishop although maybe he will because if
he takes to the king there's a check on
C5
not that scary though Bishop C5 check
you just go back to H1 and you're
threatening threatening a fork on C7
obviously
yeah I mean the fact that he took on D5
with the Knight inside of the C Pawn
tells me he wants to play
wait for you to say that
tells me he wants to play off the
advantage of the night otherwise you
would make the pass d-pawn what is this
what is this yeah strange combination of
moves I agree completely
I think Jana has sort of squandered
whatever small Advantage he may have had
now I think the position is basically
dead equal
maybe even I prefer black by a by by the
tiniest of smidges because of the slight
advantage in King safety
Quincy yeah exactly okay and now you
have to move your king up to G2 and now
there's like a nasty check on you too so
white has to be a little bit more
careful here
yeah and I think that black can
emphasize that if they can reposition
this knight from G6 back to F6
then we'll start to feel that White's a
little bit uncomfortable
and you can see John is training all the
pieces which is exactly what you want to
do when you've got problems with King
safety I think we're going to see rookie
one rookie one and likely another draw I
mean this does seem very very balanced
although we've seen the most equal of
games get crazy like yeah four moves
looking for H4 is Maxine and what do you
think of Queen D5 to just plunk in the
center and try and bail out is that
isolated upon a problem or it's okay I
think the issue with Queen D5 is we can
bring up an analysis board here trade
Rook d8
Rook D2 and Rook D6 threatening 97. I
think might be a small issue for white
yeah the other the other thing is
instead of Rook D2 white can maybe just
play Rook C2 ah and Rook takes five you
could infiltrate
yeah yeah it would have been
an interesting Canada move instead he
goes Queen F5 and now he moves back to
D3
okay just so H4 finally comes in
to me this
has a definite risk for white yeah
black owns the e-file as well
wrote back to E8
but is this really such a big problem
the isolated Pawn I think the king is
handily
defending that pawn
I think it's a little it's more of an
issue of whether the pawn defends the
king than whether the king defends the
pawn
yeah that's well put
and be all looking for ways to to twist
the knife here
for example 95 95 Rook E5 black would be
threatening mate I don't think that's
actually
very s necessarily very strong I think
there's Queen d8 to H4 back and forth
here and that's exactly what's happening
Rook back to E8 as possible if King H7
you write Queen H4
covers the main thread and
reciprocates the attack
oh maybe he wants King G6 oh he's played
it and this is not to be stealing it
this is not to be trifled with the king
is threatening Rook a tribe it's
defending the square
yeah white isn't danger all of a sudden
Rook G5
and then I guess Queen F3 is his idea
recovering the checkmates nice
the end game is slightly better for
black though better King placement and
better Pawn majority the smaller the
pawn majority the easier it is to create
a pass point
and the scariest thing to do in a
slightly bad end game is to trade into
the king and pawn ending that's always
terrifying yeah and it loses on the spot
if you take on F5 then Black's King just
infiltrates to the queen side so he has
to find King G2 here I think Dania and
accurately evaluate the draw instead he
gives up the pawn which is totally
understandable
but now black has great winning chances
C5 right before Rook D7 now Black's
gonna attack the B Pawn from behind on
B2 or maybe Rook C2 or Rook B2 I think
Rook B2
Rook A5 different oh he's going to B5
he's ready for Rook D7 so ready for it
great Square
before Rook B5 there it is
and now the black king can come over
first as well this looks really
dangerous to me
yeah I mean so the one thing is if the
black king goes to E5 white will have
then Rook D7 and collecting the whole
King side but blackhead try to race that
what black does not want to do is trade
off all the queen side pawns that's like
the fast track to a draw you want to
keep the queen side once on the board
yeah he plays the most aggressive move
now maybe C6 for white but if you go
Rook f7a5 Rook g7a4 it's it's risky
great call that's a nice defensive move
C6 BC Rook F7 he's gonna win back
another Pawn
and this is 50 50 again no idea who's
gonna win this I think it's gonna be
black or obviously White's not winning
this I meant to say it might
yeah white winning is a draw at this
point
King F2 tries to get his King into the
defense
yeah he realizes he's always got Rook B3
or Rook B2 with checks so he doesn't
need
to advance the king off oh that looks
like death that's it that's a dagger
move that's a knife right there rookie
four now you just push upon C4 C3
goodbye
see you later play C3 and white plays
Rook C7 your King's in range for King D4
got it
and if you wait here black will play
Rook C4 if you keep the king cut off and
at that point it's too late to advance
your king as you said because then C2
promotes the pawn
it's over okay
Maxine steals another point in the end
game
and he makes a real statement and a real
lead here in the match if he wins this
game that is just not a game of yawn was
supposed to lose I mean he was here I
think better for it is good I would just
go C2 and put the Rook behind the pawn
and then the problem is that even if I
wins the C Pawn this is actually a lost
end game G this is famously losing so
just King E4
it is and it's over
or King D4 and Rook C3
yeah that's it
that's why did the king go to E2 instead
of E3
not sure I'm sure there's got to be
somebody in chat who wants to know why
the king
I think away
and then King D2 okay G3
oh and then yeah yeah got it beautiful
all right finally the end total
statement game total statement game by
India with black slightly worse out of
the opening
an end game that seemed to be drawn and
he squeezed all of the juice out of that
position
yeah
okay now I don't know if I if I realized
that one day in my life I would be
rooting for the Berlin end game but I in
the early part of this match have been
waiting for my theme to go for the full
end game and now he's doing it and I'm
excited for the Berlin end game what's
happened to me give me this over rookie
one any day for sure
yeah
it's already happened to me too many
rookie One games no rookie one might be
the most lifeless just
absolute you know you know insipid line
of Chess in any opening the rookie won
Berlin
okay very very general question players
for you Dania
if there's a choice between a technical
position and an absolute like Madness
position
right who who is favored like which of
them should want to go into a technical
position which of them should want to
get just everything
I think MBL is the technical favorite
because he both of them are tactical
players obviously I mean look at mvl's
opening repertoire but mvl is a
calculating machine he's super good in
the positions where Precision is
required
whereas Jan is like I I mean he's insane
in all areas but he's so tricky so he
wants positions where there's an
abundance of you know two three move
tactical tricks right uh and and he
wants the time scrambles I still think
Jan
um well okay all out time scrambles as
we kind of discussed mvl might have the
edge but sharp positions with where both
players have like one minute on the
clock I would take yon so I think MBL
actually has to build up a two or three
point lead going into the bullet that
should be his goal
all right fair enough he's halfway he's
halfway there no one's yet been ahead by
two points in this match no one's yet
pulled ahead by that much it's been a
one point match since game one
um I've been very very impressed by
Yan's end game play but when you see two
players who are both really good at
everything it's it's interesting to
wonder if there's like anybody who's you
know when they're offering trades
they're saying they're thinking to
themselves like yeah if I can get into
like you know 100 end games in a row
that's gonna favor me a little bit whoa
fireworks
night of checkmate
Checkmate yep
and it's still Rook D1 Rook D1 doesn't
actually help it moves the piece off of
the square but doesn't get rid of the
square itself
wait how do you defend against this
because you can't just Castle you've
moved your King right no King f8 either
because uh Rook d8 is mate and Bale
takes a calm Swig and uh what is like
Rook hg8 is black smooth
I mean you might have to because you
can't remember
I wonder as long as you're threatened
with Checkmate if white can't try and
just go after the bishop that's covering
E7 like Rook HGH C3 you know and if
Bishop C5 B4
that's a problem
wait a second that's a big problem if we
if we look at that on an analysis board
Rook G8 C3
um let's let's throw in oh nope let's
throw in Rook takes two one Rook takes
D1 sure Bishop c5s before
what I think is that black can deal with
the checkmate with a move like Bishop D5
or something and then when you play B
takes oh or Bishop no Bishop D5 I take
and go C4
oh still nailing and then you go H6 but
you're gonna lose
the position completely but I think you
can go Bishop E6 instead hitting the
Knight directly with two different
pieces and if BC then obviously you take
with the bishop
okay something similar is on the board
he has played Rook G8 and he has traded
on D1 first
yeah Maxine's taking a different angle
with Rook D4 attacking the two pieces
from the side and
um
yeah black still needs to at some point
spend a move getting out of Checkmate
but
what's the idea it's like the idea is
like Bishop D5 Rook before Knight F5
Rook B7 and just get into the camp
yeah and when upon while you're at it B5
defend the bishop
and now C3 Bishop C5 hits The Rook so
you can't really combine the two ideas
the other thing that mdl can do by the
way is at some point you can just trade
everything on E7 and try and outplay the
single light scored Bishop with his
Knight like obviously our eyes are on
knockout tactical blows here
but there aren't always have to remember
like what's the scenario if we just go
into something technical here
and Knight D2 I think is one of those
Tech well it's it's it's strikes a
balance because you're threatening
you're threatening just Knight takes C4
and then trade everything on E7 take on
C4 and win the Brook End Game
and if Blackley is Bishop to C5 you can
still take on C4
because Bishop takes D4 Knight takes C7
actually hits The Rook on G8
yeah so this is not easy to to navigate
if you're if you're young
FC finally if the if the bishop went
back to a square like E6 this on D2 is
on route for the technical trade-off of
everything and then 94 Knight C5 and
that's like exactly where you want to be
if you want to beat the bishop in the
end game
great point
and Beyond taking the chaotic approach
F6 Knight takes C7
now he's deciding what to recapture with
yeah he's got to take back he can't take
on G5 I don't think in a loud Knight
takes C6 it feels like he'll just take
C8 down there
okay
definitely got to recapture
so yeah now what is he gonna take back
with
I expect Bishop takes because your
Bishop's just kind of vulnerable on B4
but there may be
a scenario where he wants to take D2
whoa
he has taken D2 now he's allowing Knight
G8 Bishop G5 and he thinks he's got the
Knight
but white
Bishop C1
I don't I don't believe this that there
must be something here for white
Knight takes G8 Bishop takes G5 there's
also f for
Bishop H4
God black is hanging by us oh and then
at five and E6 I think I got it
I think after Knight G8 Bishop G5
F4 yeah maybe that's not it but Bishop H
you're gonna let black take your knight
and trap their Bishop in there
well no you're also templing that guy
I'm definitely that guy and I want to go
E6 and you want to go E6 and then oh but
there's a check here
no that doesn't work not quite Max seems
deep into this one but if ever there was
a time to spend
your time and say this is a five minute
game not a three minute or a one minute
it's right here
yeah this next move is worth a point
there's Bishop takes F6 as well
yon sign he's found some line that he
doesn't like
okay night she had his played let's see
what mvl goes for he goes for F4
taking the commentator's advice always a
bad idea
yeah so
for four box because C5 Rook takes C4
Desperado and then you win the other
Bishop
although even there it's not over
because the night strap but anyways
yeah this is this is insane he's got to
go to H4 but he thought about it for a
bit always go F5
maybe switch the move order go E6 first
okay I'm looking at King H2 as well here
trying to trap the bishop E6 is
interesting yeah
that's so many options and this is what
I mentioned right chaotic position both
sides of a minute this is where I think
yawn stands to benefit
yeah E6 played
good move so can he take and then on F5
Play Bishop G5 there then rookie four
that's his point and there's rookie four
killing all right great calculation
okay so what can black do what are
Black's options
white could still play E7 against G6 oh
and Bishop takes G8 Rook defense seven
is a huge threat yeah he's seven to
clean things up they make some moves
giving no time no it's over Rook D7 ends
it oh
he is in there they should be six rookie
seven Rook takes G7 coming otherwise he
covers E7 with the bishop
I would just play Rook takes G7 and
clear the true memory Rook takes agents
yeah exactly exactly he's gonna clean it
up well a bishop pair is always a little
tricky for a rook to handle but if this
Rook you know clears up the entire
seventh rank it's gonna be in charge
yeah Rook takes C7 Rook takes A7 and G4
you're just going to push your king size
I think he's going to resign shortly
yeah
I just so nepo's gonna try like grabbing
A2 at some point and and trying one last
hurray on the queen side
yeah Eminem feels like no
but C3 B4 and it's never over with that
with nepo you just know he's gonna come
up with tricks I don't like them I think
mvl shouldn't not touch the whole Queen
side I think he's okay because his
rook's gonna be able to come back out on
C7 and
you know with that with that Rook
involved
yeah that Pawn's not gonna Queen Bishop
D2 though great move by nepo
that's a nasty little move right there
can you play F5
oh
this should be winning three good bring
the king up
this actually actually no this might be
a draw I don't this actually might be a
draw you wants the pawn he just Blended
the pawn
wait why did he take on C5 he should
have brought the king up first
absolutely guaranteed yes
wow that is there for MBL yeah that is a
lost opportunity
they I mean they had time I don't know
why mvl kind of rushed
I mean the whole a3c3 thing you did on
the queen side David I think you should
have just pushed G4 and run the pawns up
the board I think aneppo is way too slow
he kind of gave him kindling for the
counter play on the on the queen side
yeah that's definitely going down as
like a huge Miss for Maxine that's going
to be in his head a little bit nepo
brings out his first 1e4 game
and uh grabs a couple nuts which are my
opinion the best way to keep your energy
up
mid game mid-master great
Force back Queen d297 is a famous
blunder
yep
yeah
often black tries to push D5 and he does
otherwise white would have played C4
clamping down on the D6 Pawn
yeah okay d5's just enough I was gonna
say nepo had grabbed like a small
Advantage but I'll revised that
immediately hey
C4 another we've had a lot of uh games
with only one minor piece left on the
board
ly enough
yeah to just take on E3
probably play F6
yeah solid position for black maybe F6
F4
which is what he's trying to avoid with
Queen C7
yeah Bishop F1
I guess to me this looks like a sign of
ambition I don't think F6 F4 would be a
problem if you're happy with a draw for
black you just trade a pawn and develop
your Rooks
yeah I mean I guess mvl wants to strike
in the slower time controls that seems
to be his overall strategy
yeah is somebody saying in chat my
favorite bullet
it's very likely that this is the last
game in the five minute section
um because we've got eight minutes on
the uh on the game and four minutes on
the on the five minute timer the game
will count
yeah
um but you said something important
there you said nepo is definitely the
favorite in bullet to you
to be
well the thing is I think when both are
at the peak of their form they're maybe
comparable but nepo's just you just
played a lot more and I think bullet is
is a
uh you know bullet bullet strength is
very much correlated to how active you
are in general I don't know I'm
spitballing but I really feel like
that's something I've observed
anecdotally
like when I play a lot of tournaments
and stuff your intuition is very sharp
um and your tactics are on point so I I
think nepo is going to nepo nepo's gonna
be very happy with the tie going into
the bullet
okay should Maxime try and get his Queen
side pawns onto dark squares here
he doesn't think so but Jan does yeah
yeah in case you have that thought you
won't have that thought anymore
I mean you could play A5 and try to
carve out a weakness on C5 but the
problem is why it's just gonna push the
pawn up to C5 and he does it anyway
yeah lots of Pawns being pushed here
in fact the last like eight moves have
been with buns
okay we could have Liquidation in a
quick draw
there could actually be another game
if this one ends quickly
yes so far they've never just agreed to
a draw they've always played played it
out used the last two or three minutes
even when it seemed like the middle game
resolved quickly
we're getting
noticed in chat that
uh or someone's pointing out that mvl
played a 100 game bullet match against
Reza
yesterday which yeah I wonder why you
did that it's not like you had an SCC
match coming up and he wanted to
practice his bullet
I think he probably told Ali Reza that
that the uh candidates for the next
World Championship were starting
tomorrow tricked him into
yeah
shrieked him into some bullet just
imagine you're in Madrid and it's 2 A.M
and you're playing nepo tomorrow
and imagine I'm the commentator
yeah
okay Queens are kept on the board again
both players just trying to keep some
spice alive Queen takes C3 was kind of
drawish
wow 40 10 for alireza
damn girl
that's a big score
yeah
but it was also hyper bullet and this
one plus one is a totally different game
also in 100 games if you score 40 to 10
I mean that's a lot of double forfeits
I guess it was a 50 game match
okay somebody was exaggerating slightly
as some people are want to do
so nepo is waiting on pushing C6
um and maybe in some cases it's because
of C6 Queen B5
but yeah definitely
it also feels like maybe he's happy to
sort of have that C5 Pawn well protected
on a dark square and kind of threatening
yeah classic the threat is stronger in
the execution moment
where he's like waiting for the perfect
I think this might be the perfect moment
because see Queen takes B5 Rook C5
Forks the queen and the bishop there is
Queen B6 there and White's Making
Progress
yeah the other thing that I've learned
to watch out for is sometimes C6 B takes
C6 and then B6 like they just prefer to
have the pawn one step further out from
the center so you always have to watch
out for for B6 as well
in this case he took on C6
now White's the one pushing no doubt
about that
black spawn is totally motionless you
can't go Rook D3 because takes and The
Queen Is Lost
yeah you see it on the clock too two
minutes less for Maxine
this would be a huge confidence boost
for nepo if you can get the last game
this will be the last game of the
segment 30 seconds left I don't think
this game is wrapping up in the next 20
seconds the normal move I would play in
this kind of a position would be Rook C8
but I think white would be winning with
Rook C5 and then Rook takes F5
mm-hmm
so the bishop on F5 is a concern it's a
little bit loose
and if it moves back to G6 there's H5
but if you go Rook C5 too quickly there
was Rook D3
okay instead he pushes his Pawn straight
away oh
that is not a move you want to play cool
seventh rank
Bang
H5
comes in next move could be Rook C6
nhg Bishop H3 also a big problem
no I I think black is is collapsing here
Queen G5 trying to get the Queens off
the board
okay which might be Black's only chance
yeah so White's gonna throw in hg6
because of Queen H5 check
and then try to keep Queens on the board
okay so what is he gonna take back with
the king oh
so Queen D6 Queen F6
instead he gives this check on C6
okay back to F7 black is surviving for
now and the other thing David is that
there's this check on H5
yeah he's gonna have to block with the
bishop on F1 oh Bishop D7 is what he
missed and now you have to trade the
Queens it's gonna be a draw no way out
are you kidding me no way out there are
no checks he pulled off the draw
defensive calculation there
that that's an incredible retreating
move and it hits the Rook
and it hits the queen and there are
literally no checks on the black king no
effective checks yeah
so if I'm nepo and I've got two and a
half minutes I'm calculating Queen E4
Bishop C6 Queen C6
um but Queen H5 to D1 Etc is very safe
for black and the last thing you want to
do is lose this game
so as disappointing as the draw is
and I think E3 black black shouldn't
give this Pawn up that easily
yeah Bishop F5 looks okay as well or is
that Rook F1 gonna Wonder oh Rook F1
Rook takes oh no no then you take and go
g because we've got the G Pawn right
so you could go Bishop F5 you could go
E3
7 what do you do E3 I totally saw that
move give like
and play Bishop C8
seconds
what do you think of King E7 to D6 here
is that at all risks so I was thinking
about that there's this idea of taking
on D7 and going Bishop H3
oh nepo might still be creating chances
here
Rook d8 King E7 though black is holding
and otherwise black is ready to play E3
yeah I think also Rook d8 E3 might work
out
yep
no totally I think black is watertight
here rookie seven another idea to tie
white down to the pawn
and he just closes his eyes and pushes
Rook f8 what a move oh by the skin of
the teeth he's got eight seconds on the
clock he predicted it and that was the
only score he could go to because Rook
gape allowed Bishop to D5 with a skewer
h8 was undefended EA was defended by the
bishop so now if if King
G2
King E7 King E7 cutting the king off
Rook f8 King f8 number three King E7
King E3 King D6
for tempo
I would need 10 times as much time as
Maxine to play this simple situation
he's defending this so accurately
another great move King E7 not easy to
give up the pun of check but game D6
Forks the bishop in the pawn
yeah and then uh Rook c3s like a tricky
move there maybe but
looking nepo's still trying yeah but no
he scored some points in positions where
others would have either conceded the
draw or resigned you know like the last
game he drew with the bishop against
Rook
and he's still trying he's gonna try to
win the pawn on G5 cut the king off
but you're not getting to that pawn
you're not moving your king up to H3
because it's cut off
yeah I cannot get to that g Pawn
and now nepo down to 36 seconds okay
still keeping the Rooks on the board
this is
purely for show at this point
if I'm Maxime I'm dreaming of
checkmating on H1
yeah if you get careless wait a second
who's the one getting careless now
rookie five check
oh he's gonna lose the pawn but then
Rook F2 check
and black is attacking yeah
oh
Bishop E4
oh why does it give up the exchange and
it's still a draw but oh my gosh
only move Rook takes E4 dreaming of
Checkmate dreaming of Checkmate right
this is we can always
dream
Incredible the Incredible defensive
effort go ahead right now the French
dreaming of Victory right he's got a
one-point lead he did what he had to in
this five minute section survived some
flashes of brilliance and I'm happy with
where things stand right now
yeah I mean mvl leading Five Points to
four yawn winning the first game of the
match he thought he was going to jump
out to an early lead but but MBL he was
stable his opening choices have been
good David I mean he's basically doing
everything he needs to be doing right
now
yeah and I would like to see more of him
going for the Berlin end game when when
the match resumes with a three-minute
blitz I did not really like the rookie
One games
um but he got a really juicy game uh the
one time he went for the main end game
and so hopefully we can have some more
epic uh endgame battles here
indeed and before we go on break we
wanted to wish you happy holidays from
chess.com right now upgrade your
chest.com account to premium membership
and get one month of Premium free you
heard that right chess.com is increasing
the seven day free trial to an entire
month for those who upgrade to premium
membership right now through our website
that's one month of unlimited game
review unlimited puzzles and a cute
little Emoji next to your username for
free don't miss this limited time offer
drop X Glam lto that's exclamation mark
lto in the chat for details and
directions okay more SEC action on the
other side of this short break
foreign
Jew
on gal let me get my own let me get my
own girl
it's mine you know some of the things
that he see
I don't understand how he see it but his
mind just kind of works
on another level
but I've been I've been introduced to
this game since I was six or seven years
old and I'm 58 now
sit right there brother there's so many
different locations they play the game
at
the third one is the heartbeat of the
game
that's the heartbreaking game and I
that's how I kind of try to view it
didn't let the whole world know that
this is happening in Houston it's well
overdue
that's that's something that's been
really my dream since I started chat so
I'm you know that's my purpose it ain't
so much to win I love women though I
ain't gonna lie I'm like nearly gay
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
a storm is brewing you're never going to
beat hikarados on game not in these
positions within the Tempest the best
have come to test their skills and brave
the storm Adam's down to five seconds
gonna move
oh we missed it oh he allowed to drop
for some this is familiar ground I never
seen Madness play a move like that
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess
the moves will be fast oh my God no 97
tricked at the end the stakes will be
high he just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship GM Daniel narditsky and I
Am David prus bringing you coverage of
Beyond The Promise match against Maxim
vashilagrav the five-minute portion is
in the books and David as we take a look
at our new smarter chess prediction mvo
that one point lead is now favored to
win the whole match
yeah I'm really surprised to see it um
move that far off of a one point lead
um you know I've had you telling me that
uh that Nepal is probably a favorite in
bullet and so I thought you know one
point it's like
a close match a close match but maybe
not quite a lead yet
I mean I can see this going either way
what I I can't really see this being a
blowout I think we're gonna see more of
the same the three minute portion we're
gonna see a super close match
uh back and forth their openings have
been fairly even I mean neither side
getting a big Advantage out of any of
the openings
so I you know I can't wait to see what
what they bring to the table we've got
60 Minutes of 30 seconds sorry three
plus one chess to be played I wish it
were 30 seconds yeah unfortunately not
yet maybe next year
you know nepo has a reputation in the
Chess World for like Brilliance and
streakiness and sometimes you know going
on tilt and like crashing out at the end
of a tournament if it's not all going
his way but
um one of the things I wanted to like
Praise Him for in this segment was just
the resilience when he got into bad
positions like I have not seen him give
up on a single game at any point he's
shown so much confidence and persistence
in every position he's had so today I
see no chance of nepo like you know
tilting or giving up on the match if he
won't even give up on a single game you
know down to the last Pawn he's been
just like a dog with a bone so I think
he's going to show us just a ton of
tenacity today yeah and I mean he seems
to be enjoying the experience I mean
he's we've talked about the fact that he
seems to be all smiles he's laughing and
and that's a good thing and I think you
know we sometimes take things too
seriously as chess players it's not a
bad thing for somebody to be enjoying
their experience having a good time it
doesn't mean he's not taking the chest
seriously the moves and the record say
otherwise here they go right three plus
one time we've got 60 Minutes of it and
we have another rookie one Berlin MPL
back to more of the same oh it went so
well my friend I know when you played
the other line
and now he's like I miss rookie one
yeah what can we do we're not their
coaches we don't get to pick their
openings
um but you said something really
important there that I want to ask you
about Donya which is about having fun do
you have any feeling from your own
experience of like when you're playing
you know thousands of Blitz Games in
your life
do you play better when you've got like
a happy feeling is that something that
you've noticed
150 I play better when I'm in a good
mood like if I'm in a good mood because
of you know non-chess related things I
like 100 play better like if I've had a
good day or if I feel good that totally
translates and conversely if you're
stressed out and you've got stuff on
your mind it is very hard some people
can compartmentalize but it is going to
affect your play so you know just seems
like nepo's in a good mood today and and
you know we will ask him about it if he
wins the match
uh but I I think it most certainly
impacts your overall performance across
many games
yeah he really does look like he's
having a lot of fun I keep like thinking
like it'd be great if he had some
friends over
um you know how Magnus sometimes streams
kind of Magnus thought it was literally
opening my mouth to say that yeah that's
that's kind of like the feeling I have
I'm like but then I was wondering you
know I don't know if in the SEC you're
allowed to have a bunch of grand Masters
in the room with you even if they're
just laughing and drinking
yeah no totally
okay we have quite the shift in the
position what do you make of this
structure
I think this is the kind of thing that
uh is good for Maxime to get
um you know there's there's some lines
here also where you play Knight C3
Knight D5 and sacked up on D4 in the
Berlin and that's also been a specialty
uh where Maxime has done some of the
innovation
so I think getting this kind of a
situation with a messed up Pawn
structure for a really open Bishop pair
is uh right up his alley of what he
wants but has he got something ready for
F6 here I guess just yeah
back to G3 and say that you've induced a
weakness and of course White's next move
is Rook D1 and this is where doubled
pawns can actually be good like if you
play C4 and black plays T4 the other
Pawn can move up to C3 and challenged
upon again
so I actually kind of like these pawns
they can be used as battering rams to
pressure the D5 Pawn which is a huge
weakness in this no black is seriously
worse
as black I almost want to lose that pawn
I almost want to play seven yeah Bishop
D7 Queen D5 Bishop C6 like please
take that sick Pawn I don't want white
to play Rook D1 and C4 and put their C
Pawn on D5 yeah it's like take it with a
minor piece or a heavy piece just
whatever you do don't take it with a
pawn
yeah and instead he he is trying to keep
the pawn he's counter-attacking the C
Pawn actually Bishop F5 is a good move
C4 okay all right
so yeah
is he relying on the activity of his
pieces he's basically saying oh whoa D4
okay
weird stuff Happening Here
yeah well he has given up the pawn
successfully he may or may not take back
on C2 but
A7 is also dangling that needs to be
calculated as well I I would take it I
don't see a sink I think NEPA might have
even blunded that pawn
in the past
yeah that's that's the second time the a
Pawn's gone this uh in this match
well black is down upon scream is A5 the
dream is A5 and Maxime calculates for a
bit and thinks he can go for it
and then put the bishop on B6 anchor the
pawn to the bishop the other Pawn is
nicely defended by the F1 Bishop so
yeah I think he's safe on the queen side
I think he's just gonna squeeze this
Advantage out to a win okay if he can
get to A5 Bishop B6 I would be confident
that in a slow game it's a it's a
winning advantage
as it is given the time situation right
now nepo down to 45 seconds I've been
very impressed with mbl's time
management in this match thus far and in
the early going of the three-minute
portion
yeah okay calmly gets rid of back rank
mate
in a way that favors his light squared
Bishop we've got all sorts of
celebrities in the chat Jeffrey Zhang
Levy Rosman
is in the chat as well welcome everybody
nice
that tells you what a match it is I know
what a match it is if people are
watching instead of doing their own show
unmissable
look at that Bishop on B6 yeah
yeah I would have loved to torture the
B7 Pawn you know with G3 Bishop G2 but
black was gonna Lodge a bishop on C6 and
it was going to be unassailable I guess
he's still gonna do it I guess Bishop C6
is coming next and you know white has to
be very careful because the Knight can
jump out to F4 and then the blink of an
eye White's King could get caught on the
crossroad because the Bishops are not
exactly
in Prime defensive position right I mean
you would say that C4 C5 move from White
was pretty committal right
yeah mvl has now kind of realized like
wait a second I need to defend my king
and Bishop F1 is a very wise move
because you don't want to get checkmated
here
I'm I'm not confident that we're winning
anymore oh okay seven counter-attacking
the queen
yeah it's kind of a three result game
now like rookie one
rookie one would set up some checkmates
not having it he has rookie seven good
moves like
he's like I did want this to be a two
result game at minimum wage take takes a
knight F3 almost works
no way Queen d8 to D3 but I guess that
is almost nice
I didn't see that though oh we missed it
going for some version of it has he
blundered he blundered queen d8 queen D3
and David refutes
mpl's Not Gonna Miss This Again they
keep following my advice it's twice now
that they're going for my blunders
any French people in chat are they
starting to get excited or is it just
the beginning
I can't believe he actually I that
actually just walked into that what that
looked really implausible to me but it
is easy to miss because you look at that
Queen enough three you say oh there's no
way to stop mate queen d8 queen D3
forcing the queen trade and keeping the
extra piece
mvl for the first time this matches up
by two
back to the night orth
I feel so validated that nepo actually
you know fell for it too
when I do lessons uh when I give
students a problem and they answer with
the move that was played in the game I
always say there are good news and bad
news right good news that you played
like you know whatever GM that's right
like Smee sloth bad news it's a game
exactly
foreign
end game
all right an end game yeah and he takes
back with the g-pawn that was
interesting
um rather than the bishop trying to get
a little bit more Central influence
huh C4 looks like white is better here
D6 Pawn is weak why could meet this with
F4 or you could play it more I mean you
don't even have to do anything you have
the B6 Square kind of like in the last
game
anything is there is there a world where
I would want to consider B5 just trading
off some pawns because I'm worse there
you definitely would consider it I I
yeah B5 is a serious Canada move here I
would be worried about giving white the
passer though especially because the
bishop controls B6
I don't like this I think black is
clearly worse I don't know what to do
when I'm worse I just panic and Play
Moves Like B5 so like it's like just
tell me if I'm gonna win or lose this
game like I yeah get on with it already
yeah no there's nothing worse than
getting like tortured for 50 moves
against against the 2700 So he
repositions the C6 takes up takes a page
from Jan's defense yes uh in the
previous game which almost held up which
was almost yesterday
yeah
I think for John it actually was
yesterday
Rock Solid did he just serious the line
and we get your move F4 eventually
unpleasant to deal with
yeah yeah I mean black just has no real
counter play black kind of has to oh my
God sit around in a Blitz game I would
plunder into just centralizing my king
on F7 at Bishop H5 chat
very easy to blunder that and look at
Jan so technical trading off Black's
only good Bishop leaving him with a dud
on f8 ugh at least our King can come out
now but you still gotta win this like
black will hold
oh Rook takes C5 he didn't want to take
with the pawn and allow The Rook
infiltration to D7
bad pawns block good files oh nice nice
one
Hanging On by the skin
Bishop F4 but then Rook C5 okay
and I think black blackheads both Rooks
off the board I think it's a draw
yes
I agree
so let me show this on the analysis
board such a tempting move right Bishop
F4 is so natural but after Rook C5 you
have to trade Rooks because you're going
to lose the A5 Pawn otherwise and here
black has a fortress
yeah just
everything's defended
sorry you were gonna say something no no
no that's that's that's great
um what I was going to point out is that
MPL is playing quickly despite the bad
position this game and he's even like
leaning back and like taking a snack
here so I I think one of the reasons
that this kind of situation goes really
badly for a lot of us is that we stress
about all the bad things that can happen
get low on phone
it's another way to lose other than
lashing out right
oh totally and actually most of these
types of positions are lost because
players lash out because they can't sit
around and wait but top GMS don't really
have this problem and we take it for
granted that they just defend so many
bad positions successfully look at that
the moment the bishop comes off C5 he's
ready for it
it's like he's just got like the full
vision of the board
yep he did not wait an extra second but
the good news for white is that he can
keep the Rooks on the board the bad news
is that you're making progress he has to
worry about D5 but he's got rookie three
to E7 and Bishop B4 oh nice and then
King F4 so White's not able to liquidate
black doesn't need to look I mean rookie
forges but you're Rook there and chill
just hangs on
white can't play B4 you'll drop the C4
Pawn
all right Bishop f8 Bishop E7 or yeah
whatever Bishop G5 he was better that
Rook looks active enough to save the
world on e4
saving Black's position that's for sure
oh
don't give up the pawn on B3 though yawn
he's trading this game he's trading but
rookie 6 King E5 is concerned I think
his plan was oh no
that would not be so good and if Rook B6
also Bishop E3 I think he has to go Rook
D5 check but then King E4 and white is
obviously much worse now
obviously that King's gonna get stuffed
into the corner and worry about
checkmates okay so he's loud Bishop C5
and then Rook D5
yeah so he'll he'll give up the bishop
temporarily and then win it back he's
still worse though
yeah he's he's definitely worse than
Black's got like a few things they can
try here uh Bishop E3 followed by F4
um
I mean you could take
and then position the King on e4 and
push whites King back to the first
string I don't know if that's enough to
win though probably not probably not
foreign yeah I think
F4 is going to be the next move here I
like F4 a lot it's a good way to keep
the tension I guess there's Rook D5
check he need for
that feels dangerous for white right
like if we can get a pawn totally for
black
oh he goes King F4 interesting wrinkles
choosing to go into G3
and he could even move into H2
in fact I would do that
he takes his eye off the F5 pod so this
is the moment
okay A little repetition okay he just
decides he decides not to pursue it
which makes sense I mean he's he held
successfully he's up by two why Press
Your Luck right
yep and he probably calculated some line
and found your defense for nepo and said
okay yep wait a minute
it's not the Berlin Berlin not the
Berlin doing my not the Berlin dance
song made its way to the Top 100
Billboard hits
yeah
yeah casproth would would love that one
no for sure instead they're going down
another very topical line I've had this
a bunch recently
and the move the main move here is B4
right yeah Knight C6 Bishop G5
I had I just had this exact position
again boom boom boom back and forth
they're fast these guys are fast three
minutes left out of three minutes yeah
but they both have this a zillion times
in classical games
and Knight D5
okay follow up C4
follow-up C4 in most cases or even A4 in
some cases but a48 takes B4 on your Rook
hangs
yep so nepo stops it immediately A5
stops all those moves Speedy Gonzalez
here and John Queen
A1 that's my contribution I love putting
putting pieces on a closed file like
this it produces a nice aesthetic effect
yeah
the most famous incident of that was
Kasparov karpov their last match game
in 84 I think when Gary puts his Rooks
on E7 and E8 and he's got a Pawn on E6
and back then it was like shook the
world and he won that game to get the
title and now it's yeah you know just
same old oh yeah yeah that's how to play
the uh the uh
a hedgehog yeah exactly
the the doubling of Brooks on the E5 was
even more shocking than the queen in the
corner
yeah
yeah it was it was it was mind-blowing I
mean so many things are mind-blowing in
the 80s on and off the board now we just
we're sold you were so jaded
yeah
okay he's planning Knight A5 Rook B2 C6
C4 he's trying to pressure along this
file
yeah Rook B2 on the board Queenie it's a
nice move defend the Rook so you can
speak on A4 or on C4 yeah and it's
critical C4 bc4 Rook B8 Rook B8 tags
your queen C4 bc4 Bishop A5 there's
Rook B2 tagging your queen again
and uh if he plays Bishop takes A5 just
to get C4 he sacks the a pawn and he
doesn't come out with any real advantage
yep
no it looks like black is solved
most of his problems still still some
residual pressure okay time for a little
truce little h3h6 time
throw those moves in and now go back to
fighting
solid Napa with a minute lead on the
clock here so
you know he's kind of just saying like
sure what you got mvl what you got I
just
I'm feeling comfortable well I'm y'all
saying I got pressure on your B5 Pawn I
got a doubled Rooks on the B file
and a queen that's sort of nicely
sandwiched between the Rooks and the
pawn
despite the X-ray the A3 Pawn is pretty
safe the C4 square is controlled I think
the position is approximately balanced
maybe even A4
yeah
now that Queen's not looking good on on
A2
I'm gonna say she's like stuck on the
same files that Rook on A8
does not feel very good is black
considering C4 at some point or even B4
on Knight C3
like if white plays 94 I think B4 is
super strong
b4a takes B4 Knight C3 that's the
question that white is confronted with
right here
he's amazing too
C3 would have been the other important
question for white trying to trying to
hold black off and make room for the
queen
he went D5 instead he opens the second
front in the center
and this way he's also threatening
Knights yeah he could still go B4 at
some point such as now
in fact I think he very well might and
he does
oh my god I've got a crazy idea okay a
takes B4 Knight C3 no it doesn't work
because the Knight takes yeah
wait where's the line I had a terrible
idea to play a takes B4 allowing Knight
C3 and then B take C5 oh oh and if the
Rook takes on a to then Rook B8 yeah if
it were only the Rooks and for only the
rucks but the knights hitting the queen
and she's hitting the queen in the live
position as well we're getting an
exchange sack
uh but this is winning for black
before black played B4 I was starting to
think of exchange sax for white as an
escape valve with Rook takes B5 Queen D5
but
yeah The Rook should beat the Knight on
the open board here so it's very
important if white wins the C3 Pawn back
then he's got drawing chances I'm
worried he won't be able to do that
Queen C6 here Queen E7 Queen takes C
through Rook C8 so
White's gonna have to actually give up
one of his own pawns potentially because
Knight A4 tries to prevent black from
winning the A3 Pawn easily
is pretty easy I think nepo's gonna pull
he better pull this one out he has to
capitalize on this opportunity
yeah I guarantee it what okay Rook C8
that's his idea I hope Rook C8
uh if only the queen were better
defended there'd be Knight D5 to E7 oh
nice calculation but Queen B4 and again
mvl creating some difficulties here for
nepo he missed Queen before uh oh here
we go with this again Rook C5 might be
forced a rookie a great move no discover
checks there is yeah Queen G4 Queen G4
oh then Queen C1 Queen F4 the idea from
the two games ago nice
holding it together
you might still do it though and try to
seek his Fortunes in the end game but I
think that's lost
okay yeah I think
I think this one's coming to an end
pretty quickly
yeah Queen B5 the last question on that
E Pawn
but he was ready to lift The Rook
G4 still trying
they say as long as you've got a knight
there's a hope
especially in Blitz and that's 150 true
I've seen so many games and listen this
is a three on three with an a pawn it's
not over yeah yeah yeah yeah now that
that pawn traded it's not completely
over I'm surprised by that pawn trade
yeah I mean nepo's I would trade and go
Rook A6 and try to win that a pawn and
then I think it's a win
but it's not Elementary he wants to put
the pawn on H5 now
it's totally not Elementary to win this
the knight's Super Active
but it's winning
yeah okay zoom's wrong and then Force F4
and then go back and then
yeah Rook B3 Etc
92.
sanitation keeps them out still but F5
is going to come at a very bad moment
even here at 594
F4 check putting the king in a box right
and then the black king gets the H3
Square
just don't blunder 96. okay he allows it
but he he sees that he can go King H4
and push the white king back to the
first strength this is over
so so
Maxine decides to keep him out of the H4
Square for the moment
and holds up the defenses a little bit
longer still still holding him and it's
crazy yeah Jan's just kind of panning
for gold and now he trades but
okay eval bar is showing that it's over
oh you can give the Rook up for the
night I think
Rook H2 now Rook H2 seems to trap him
and then Rook to F2
I would have
okay Rook D2 beautiful oh great
knowledge of theoretical end games that
was not easy
I'll definitely I think I'll show that
David if you think that's just like why
that's winning yeah show it to us
there's a lot of people like wait I
learned
after King takes D4 first of all it's
important that black wins the punt you
get shouldered this is called
shouldering you keep getting pushed out
and pushed out and pushed out eventually
lose the pawn and you say hey but I've
got opposition but when the king reaches
the third ring and the pawn reaches the
fourth rank it's still winning King G3
King G1 F3 and then famously you go F2
zugzvan for white now King E2 King G2
you promote the queen so famous but
nonetheless not easy to remember this in
time pressure Jan heard from under
pressure
yeah it means the same Rook versus
knight by end game by the way folks with
the pawns on F4 and F5 instead of F3 and
F4 you could not ever
sack The Rook for the night to win the
king implant ending good point because
the king and plan ending would always be
a draw so that would be like an extra
difficulty level
um I think there's one thing we should
learn from that it's that even though
the Rook verse Knight is like you know
technically winning in Super Jam
classical chess in a blitz or bullet
game very few of us would have the
technique to confidently
put Maxime away in that end game he got
it down to the last Pawn
no he I mean it's crazy how close these
gems always come they never die I think
they can sack The Exchange here
it's very tempting for sure Rook takes
C3 is the classic
the classic
yeah
the trick is that after Bishop B6 Queen
C6 defends the Knight on e4
I think it'll be fine I had that
position recently and it was really
really okay
there he goes and he follows up with D5
which is another
yeah he could have had the same position
with y'all not having the pawn I'm
pretty sure like exactly yeah a little
bit odd definitely probably not enough
comp like objectively speaking but
practically I I really like this
decision
yeah so in this position part of the
idea is that like if you Outpost this
Knight on C3 The Rook on A1 is not a lot
better than a minor piece
okay hide the king from the tactics hide
the king from the tactics
yeah get it out of the diagonal
okay I mean looks like white should be
better here yeah I would think the
smallest of edges to White here not
quite sufficient he looks
oh he's looking at Bishop G5
we should probably play the problem is
the knife is better Square
and after Rook D1 tonight's gonna be
forced onto a better Square yeah it's
gonna go towards F4
ultimately the problem is the white is
two Rooks and black is one
that's just an issue fundamental
yeah E4 Maybe
hit the pawn on B the B7 Pawn is
actually quietly become a serious
weakness
because it can't move
yeah
oh and a nice thing about this
it also covers H7
oh so you might have some back rank
action later on you have to be careful
like if your plan here is you know
Knight E6 or G6 to F4 or whatever
Knight C1 White NOW repositioning his
Knight and then obviously most end games
are going to be in White's favor yeah
especially here I would not take on C2
and allow Knight D3 at the end of the
line both pawns are hanging
not good
yeah
uh on the other hand if black could snag
the A5 Pawn here that is something I
would be very interested in as black
that releases that losing scenario on
the queen side
where you drop the B Pawn and then you
lose so that pawn I was very interested
in an mdl as well decides he wants to
buy that one
the downside is that white is now fully
optimized his Knight and his Queen
and White's obviously going to win one
of the pawns back the question is which
one
you could snag another Pawn on C2 while
you're at it
but then you allow white stroke to
infiltrate the seventh rank unopposed
yeah here Rook this is the line I was
calculating and after Rook C2 Rook B8
your Knights forced back again white
gets 95 and it looks like you're just
gonna get your king defeated
yep
Rook takes C2 I mean at this point black
has to go oh
take it because
of the maid
did Nepal play like a really painful
wrong move order here
well I did not have to rotate first oh
and now Bishop E3 attacking The Rook I I
think he did but white has Rook B8 oh
look at this queen takes G2 is the
threat
oh there's no time for Knight takes G6
or Knight takes F7 or anything good I
think white might have to apparently
what is a draw
no it doesn't have a draw why it's worse
because you don't have a good defense
against Queen takes G2 and rooksy when
I'll show this really quickly boom
that's insane boom mate goodbye okay
back to the live position here we see
how fast he pounced on Queen D2
immediately immediately
and does he have a rook C1 another
Sucker Punch
ow ow another Sucker Punch and rooksy
won by the way Bishop G1
Roxy one is an amazing move that's going
to be underrated in like commentaries
because that actually without that move
I think white could even be winning like
if you had taken on G1 then after Rook
B8 and Knight takes F7 white was
threatening Rook h8 mate so this is an
important Cog in the machine
yeah holy smokes
it's over Black's winning
oh my goodness
reactions from the players how do they
feel
just just another day at the office yep
just another Mega Queen sacrifice an mvl
makes lemonade out of lemons I mean that
was crazy
and guess what he's going to be up by
two again that was a point he should not
have had I I I was ready to write him
off I mean if Rook ba checked first was
it done or was there still a problem
I think that's what he should have done
and this is Checkmate well Knight G1 I
guess technically but Bishop takes q1
back and the bishop goes back yeah well
boom back to E3 back to G1
okay the plot thickens what a game
yeah I mean we've got a heck of a match
but
um it is looking tough for nepo to uh to
to keep up in the blitz portion
yeah I mean nepo is just
you know he's on the receiving end of
some incredible form
by MBL thus far and again he's following
he's on schedule for for being up by two
or three going to the bullet which is
what I think he needs
if he wants a series shot at it okay we
have another kind of different version
of the real Lopez I feel like nepo had
this against Magnus in their world
championship Fabby by the way welcome to
Fabby he's in the chat as well all sorts
of royalty joining us today David nice I
guess um I guess beating Arjun got him
really pumped for this event because he
was watching yesterday too
nice
and you know there is that feeling Donya
when you're playing in a tournament like
if you lose your game you just go up to
your room and sulk but if you win your
game you like walk around the tournament
Hall checking out other people's games
oh totally yeah
yeah you guys are okay
yeah okay it's like when you know you
knocked out the first recital and now
you're watching the other competitors
yeah and you know you're into the next
stage it's a good feeling and if you
lose yeah you don't want to check the
tournament standings you don't have
anything to do with it yeah
okay so what's happening here MBL trying
to position a knight on F5
and the typical reaction by nepo but uh
White's building up some serious heat on
the king side I like this for Maxime
again
yeah it feels a little scary for black
to me there's um positional dangers long
term on D5 because he's kind of
transposed around to a ruby slash uh
night or structure himself and then
there were storm clouds on the king side
so
yeah oh Knight takes H6 what am I
missing
yeah this is like breathe it out of the
way of it and move a gun
but this is this is still this is the
first time I'm sensing tilt from nepo
now he opens up the video on D3 He needs
to win a piece on the D file or he will
regret what he has just done
and I I think Knight F5 can even be
considered here for white which
basically forces takes he takes F5 and
up E Pawn or that F Pawn rather can
advance to F6 once the queen moves away
I like Knight F5 as a low risk option
here
mm-hmm
and mvl has to capitalize on this brief
tilt the break and knock on soon enough
for nepo
okay if I'm white for some reason I just
want to defend my Bishops I want to play
like you know Bishop C2 or Rook 81 or
some
something to cover them
but he plays your move
oh no sorry
I mean you could play it now
he does this looks winning
this looks so basically winning Knight
F4 is chaotic
I suppose after Bishop takes F4 it's
good enough
white will always be crushing in an
opposite colored Bishop scenario here
yeah the Queen's on the board for sure
and now yeah you go Queenie Thor or do
you
take it before I mean
I would take and go Queen E4 and try to
force rook h8 and then give a nice juicy
check on D4 bring the other Rook up to
a70 Black is totally falling apart here
this is the big chance big chance for
Maxine
got a challenge as well
yep
and a three-point lead that's the big
one that's the threshold
and if you yawn you can't let the match
get out of control and in the second
half of this portion
FPL is a great bullet player obviously
Queen E4
well look at the time disparity be all
down two minutes
yeah rookie four trying to get the Rooks
involved and his idea is Bishop D5 he
has a check on G4 but I don't love what
he's doing here he's trading a bunch of
pieces I think that gives nepo practical
chances yeah the point of bringing out a
rook was not to trade a rook so he
underestimated Bishop F5 I want to say
still should be winning obviously
with the combination of the extra pawn
and blacks ruined
kingside Pawns
yeah does he have Rook A6 here he
doesn't go for it
backs up the pawn oh it gets to advance
another Square every square is a mile
now he forces the queen tree but that
doesn't mean it's totally over right
oh but then you drop B4
oh right he's just gonna take on B4 he
doesn't have to take that G4 and then
King H2 G3
yeah note that he didn't just take on F3
he wants to take on his own terms he's
going to be up two pawns yeah this
should be a this should be winning Rook
F4 and then take F7 and take after seven
first
great technique at the end there
that's two full pawns and he's got the
game in his sights and
I don't know I gotta ask a question
maybe maybe Jan played that a little bit
too quickly that game right no doubt
about that especially but blundering
Knight takes H second that is it that is
you know basic Betty right there that
that's something he should never blunder
and he's hung a couple pawns this match
and he's staring down the barrel of a
three-point deficit David this is
getting serious I think the the little
break in the middle of the three minute
couldn't have come at a better time for
yawn because that was his only bad game
of the match that one just now and uh
now he's got a chance to uh to quickly
re-center and show us his toughness
and we will see if he has that toughness
in store he has some coming back to do
and he will try to do it on the other
side of this break you are watching the
speed Chess Championship round of 16.
we'll be back with more nepo against
um against mvl on the other side of this
break stay tuned
check out chess.com's newest mobile
release for Android and iOS now with
game review
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play use
retry mistakes to get another shot at
finding missed opportunities
game review is available today on both
Android and iOS
download our app and try it yourself
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship we are watching Jana
palmistry taking on Maxime vashia lagrav
in another round of 16 matchup alongside
International Master David Bruce David
it has been all entertainment thus far
we could not ask for a higher quality
match as mvl leads by three points yeah
usually I'm not a huge fan of uh
swindles
um I like to see the person with the
advantage kind of
convert it beautifully but that game
with Queen D2 which really surprised me
and I think was really the point that uh
that Nepal let it get away
that was still a beautiful move Queen D2
and the follow-up sequence no that was
up to T1 and that that Queen G2
Checkmate threat that you came up with
and that Maxime obviously also came up
with
um that that was just really
scintillating and uh electrifying for me
so I think I think Maxine really lit uh
nepo up with that I think you know there
was a little bit of a shock felt when
when he stole that point
no that was gorgeous and I need to make
a small correction I mentioned that MBM
won the SEC he has not won the SEC but
he came very very close in 2020 that was
the year I think he defeated Magnus he
lost to Hikaru Nakamura in the finals I
mean no shame in losing to Hikaru
Nakamura obviously if that's a shame
everybody can be ashamed right yeah
literally every person in the world has
something to be ashamed about he is the
reigning world splits champion and you
do not win that tournament by accident
so one of those guys who's just
consistently underestimated alongside
Fabby and let's see if Jan can untilt
himself kind of maintain his composure
and chip away at this lead he might not
be able to tie the match but if he can
bring this down to two or even one he'll
be really happy yeah and and I'm gonna
predict that he will I think he he's
looking loose I saw him bobbing a little
bit on the break I think I think he's
fine no problems he's gonna shrug it off
it was it was one brutal Swindle and one
bad game
um but I think he's going to be coming
right back at it and he's choosing a new
approach
uh to to uh to the opening as well here
our first game with Knight F3 he started
the match off with some D4 games then he
switched to several E4 games
I like this I I think that's what you
need to do you need something fresh
a new type of position a little a little
bit of inspiration and here we have kind
of a queen's gamut accepted type of
structure in fact we could get a
transposition to a queen's gamut
accepted usually black plays B5
and white can take on C5 sometimes goes
D5
and sometimes just keeps the tension as
Jan does here all right so Queen C2 the
queen eyes C5 and C6 we'll ask you need
to play a move that defends those
squares a little bit
either Bishop B7 or queen B6 something
in that direction
I think the other idea is to play DC and
the Knight takes B5 so mvl tries to
defend everything at once with Queen B6
right
laughs
but the downside is that that doesn't
develop a minor piece then yeah D5 I
think it strikes in the center and black
is lagging on the king's side
yeah that's that's the big risk of Queen
B6
um versus just Bishop B7 and castling
with the queen still on d8 but I guess
he was worried that without Queen B6
maybe something like dc5 Bishop C5
Knight B5 would be enough even with
Knight defended on C6 that that he might
drop a pawn
um now nepo I mean he's got some media
tactical threats he also has the
possibility of just playing you know E4
with the central majority
and with his last move Queen to E4 he
was preventing Blackbird castling like a
castle Bishop takes C6 and queen takes
E7 would have won a piece so NBL trying
to reshuffle rejigger his pieces here to
be able to Castle it's easier said than
done though right Bishop takes D5 Rook
takes the and then even if you do Castle
doesn't necessarily solve all of your
problems right he's going to do some
unusual work with this Rook here now we
also got to watch out for the Rook on A8
in this position
um you know we still can't Castle
because of Queen E7 but um on every move
we gotta watch
tactical options for that Rook
yeah 96 Rook takes C5 snags a pawn
so maybe Rook C8 is worth considering
here not an easy move to play Love Queen
G6
attacking the source of the problems
that's right yeah rather than the
symptoms
nice Rook F5 no very challenging move he
wants to follow up if possible with 95
after something like Rook C8
for sure 95 Queen E6 blacks Queen
zigzagging around the sixth Rank and
doing a damn good job of it too that
Rook is is certainly weird
H4 trying to go H5 get off me
he says to the black queen
oh
Queen's like no
now Rook D5 Queen G6 Rook F5 would be
humorous
I don't like the Berlin draw
but I've never seen this one so
you might get that although I think
Jan's gonna be a lot less keen on the
repetition given that he's down by three
and he's got the white pieces here I
think he's gonna go Rook F5 and then
move his Queen
yes we're just Queen can't back up from
here because nope the G6 Queen is
covering
the squares
he's putting a lot of effort into it it
might seem like thinks he's got it
dialed in all right Queen to G4 that's a
good area for the board to be in
yeah but now white is probably worse
this can also go wrong for white because
those pieces could be weird
yeah and black black could try to set
his like c500 motion but it's again that
is also easier said than done because
white can bring the bishop up to C3
so the big question to me is like
whether white will be able to make
something of this concentration of
pieces or is it as you said going to be
it end up as a drawback
H5
played largely against black playing G6
here I don't think we're going to see
white play H6 G6 under the present
circumstances Bishop H6 he was well King
ha now he's got to move the bishop back
now he's got to move back
probably to E3
stop Knight D4
crazy position
just weird Play All Around yeah
it should be three played
what now for black is he gonna go Knight
D4 anyway
for white I really want to play moves
like Knight G6 check you know so I'm
looking at Rook F7 and I really need G3
King G2 for the tactics to work out as
far as I can see
yeah if you had a rook on H1 that would
Empower you in a big way yeah even just
having access always work yeah
Bishop D6 defensive extra with the queen
yeah good point
okay night about back to F3 maybe trying
to push E5
that doesn't do all that much the bishop
just moves back now he goes H6
ooh poking and prodding Rook 81
this is getting unpleasant for black
mm-hmm
yeah it's been intense how's he doing
he's got 30 seconds
on the clock that's not a lot
not a lot Bishop's amazing on C3 oh the
best piece on the board Queen H4 Queen
F6
Queen H4 ends it I think
because you're also pressuring The Rook
so the Knight can't move
oh that's it that's game right there
wow
just look at how his pieces are arranged
in the final position just everything is
on a perfect square yeah and forces a
bloodless resignation right no captures
no checks no tactics just equal material
took over
he crushed him that game and it seemed
like mvl was you know on on the mend but
but all of a sudden within the span of
like three moves Yan reinvigorated the
attack and and it was just over
yeah you know MBL played one sort of
loose move thinking there was no threat
coming which was C5 C4
and then Jan sort of like swung around
the bishop to C3 with the pawn on H6 and
suddenly it was it was terminal if the
paunted bit still been at C5 and B5
there would have been B4 as a resource
for black so there was one loose move
there where Maxine thought he'd escape
the danger
but little did he know it was all part
of the plan okay yarn cuts the lead down
to two this is a big game very big game
18 minutes left on the match clock in
the three-minute segment we'll have 30
minutes of bullet
to conclude the match after this
but these are really decisive games we
have another different opening this
one's sort of very non-theoretical kind
of a modern double fan keto generally
white slightly better in these
structures but
is the kind of kg player who does well
with black hair yeah and he's got a
pretty acceptable version of it like
he's managed to grab a bunch of space on
the queen side without any disaster he
didn't allow an early E5 or D5 that was
good for white
my personal feelings anytime you come
back from a little break you need to
score a point again to sort of like
start over on the match and believing on
yourself so even though Maxime has the
lead in the match they take a short
break they come back
NEPA wins a game it's like Maxine needs
to win a game in order to have a good 30
minutes here
totally and the way this game is going
uh it's not very reassuring I think
after Queen takes F3 Knight D5 white is
gonna have a very hard time defending
the E5 Pawn
against the knight in the bishop I think
Maxine just missed Bishop takes F3 very
strong Intermezzo Bayan and he's better
and he's up on time again
my incentives should still be a way for
white to be okay but oh
something I'd be willing to do
I'd rather just lose my E5 Pawn just you
you can have my E5 Pawn I'm not I'd
rather get my finger I mean this is this
is just like
I mean oh and he drops the pawn on the
queen side now what MBL is saying he's
got some stuff in return let's not yeah
I mean this is this is more double-edged
than it seems yeah he's saying he kept
the bishop on G7 out of the game for now
so we're gonna see Yan trying to still
focus on the F4 Square here right Queen
H4 Bishop H6 is on his agenda
yeah and if the black queen moves away
and then H4 H5 somehow these pawns as a
standalone unit are not that bad but
here we go G5 great move by Yan and this
is disgusting yeah now now he's
established his Advantage beyond a
shadow of a doubt there's some random
Pawn mask for white on the king side
that's not very mobile and he's got you
know two nights in the four Center
squares an open fiancated bishop and a
pass C Pawn
yep that's a list
that's quite a few advantages and Bill
trying to
wheel his way out of it but now you
might have to go F4
trying to preserve the pawn structure
now he's down another Pawn
yeah but he did the thing you told me
about like when it's going completely
wrong
mess something up don't you just don't
just let yourself lose in the obvious
way that your opponent's already sort of
pictured
no you have to have to shake up the
situation so here Bishop B7 he's
thinking a while about it though
and then Rook C7 would fall into Bishop
takes A5 he takes n A5 immediately oh
actually that's why he was realized he
thought it might already be a spot
black might want a second exchange here
but that's quite the decision Rook takes
D6 and Knight takes F4 Also let's not
forget why does this past a pawn but you
could run up the board really quickly
yeah great job here I'd rather just play
Knight F4
oh you're right and recapture on d8
because I'm concerned I need to be able
to break the E5 Square as black
great call
it's on the board now opposite colored
Bishops as well gives more attacking
chances you know Rook D2 kind of ideas
white absolutely can't allow
Ed to get that out
it's a maid threat the rookie one you
know we trade and take E5 and
everybody's out
mm-hmm
rookie four instead now maybe Rook F1
s and making it a three result position
in your opinion like totally are there
scenarios where he just randomly wins
with the a pawn now oh 100 I mean Jan's
in fact I would say that White's
probably not worse at this point I don't
know exactly where Yan's big mistake was
but the game has turned around largely I
think it's now just unclear wow anybody
well maybe maybe it was Rook ac-8 like
it looks so innocent right but Bishop B5
to C6 he plays Rook C8 and maybe he
didn't see that and they all could grab
on A5 there yeah he he probably blunted
another Pawn
well now his Knight is hanging it's not
easy to find a good Square for the night
and most importantly White's King is now
not just safe but an actual attacker
yeah advantage
person that H4
still dangerous
United V8
I didn't like King G2 by the way I think
after Knight H4 King H3
wait King H3
yeah G2 Bishop D3 defends F1
and that's what he missed
oh NEPA might have walked himself into
another
another very nasty situation I don't see
how you actually have saved the piece
here what is he supposed to do now about
the Knight on The Rook
apparently rookie 3 is the only move but
then white takes and takes G3 oh to play
G2 G1 oh I should win that anyway
unbelievable all right John you gotta
find that come on man you want to win
the magic be a genius
but the promise even after that like
white can just take the pawn on G3 he
goes G2 no but this is losing oh that's
it it has to be losing that's it that's
it for this game
is that it for the match I don't know
but now I've got like a feeling like mvl
is going to be confident through the
rest of the three minute portion
I don't know if the game is the game is
totally over though A4 Bishop D2 D2 just
in time to stop the pawn he's still
hoping for a fortress here in fact
he's untrapping it though untrapping it
are you willing to play Bishop G5 and
let this Pawn get to A8 no well you can
take and go back to D2
coming around to A8 and pushing the a
pawn
yeah he doesn't care about any of his
other Pawns in fact there are no other
pawns yeah no there's just one of them
he has shown that he absolutely doesn't
care about them but 87 King 86.
oh you're telling me he wasn't locked
into taking it
nope
F4 yawn it's actually a three years old
goodness he's amazing at saving these I
know it's crazy but I don't know what
the evaluation is F3 it's a total three
result C3
oh black might win this black absolutely
might win this oh yeah trying to bail
out
it's oh Knight D6 barely
oh my Lord
now that's some resilience that's some
resilience right there
honestly an incredible save and it's
it's a shame that he's still down by two
like that kind of game should should
earn you like two points
but it's just a draw in this case it's
half a point I mean they each had an
incredible save mdl found his moment
with Bishop B5 Bishop A5
um when the game was going completely
South
yeah I mean it's easy to forget nepo was
winning out of the opening in that game
it's it almost feels like it was a
different game but no that was the same
game where nepo or mvl took on F3 with a
pawn
causing
reactions from us
I predicted
mdl is going to come out of this opening
okay this game
I agree with your prediction this is
going to be an opening success
see you in a castle queenside to defend
that b-pawn
maybe white as a tiny little something
here given a chance to play I thought
maybe bishop F6 was going to come last
move but it didn't
so now rookie 8 he would Castle Queen
side so mvl is thinking about Bishop G5
Bishop G5 to cut off
access to the C file and to prevent
castling yeah
okay
is there anything with Bishop F5 or is
there nothing
foreign
Vegas Bishop D3 is he straight up
allowed that yeah that point there would
be to then give the bishop check trade
and get the Rook to E2 at least
nice calculation I like that idea he
gives instead a check on C8
but that seems like a paper tiger yeah
that's random now the a pawns hanging
must be attended to White's got an edge
big Edge and the eBay bar keeps growing
Black's gonna lose a pawn here
very loose
yeah I wish
wait why didn't he take on D5 there
because I missed back rank mate
he just didn't see the back right bait
he was going too fast man
he's got two minutes and 50 seconds out
of three minutes he can't see everything
weird but he's still I mean he still has
great winning chances in this end game
but that's still these are the misses
that he just can't afford when you're
down by two you know yeah you just
you've got to capitalize on these
opportunities
yeah
but you might still win this
yeah Black's got to absolutely Scramble
for Rook activity here there's no other
solution to positions like this
um
okay King D4 centralizing is King
Rook C5 is Maxine has saved some
terrible end games today we just gotta
say he has saved some bad bad end games
he prepares Rook A5 King E5 that was
that was slick to come right back the
resilience has been off the charts no
question about it
yeah
okay King E3 now don't go rookie six and
allow Kings E4
yeah it's a it's a fight over this F4
move and uh he had to calculate quickly
there King E5 F4 Rook F4 Rook D5
and uh that rook and fun ending looked
bad for black so he played G5 instead
yeah and he's basically holding the
forward he's saying hey you can't make
progress King D4 always met with Rook F4
you can't play G3 because you drop F3
and Rook A5 as you pointed out king E5
looks like black is surviving so maybe
this is why it's only a chance
infiltrate and try to go from the back
side so I'm thinking H5 H4 for black
because that H7 pun's a little bit
vulnerable but I guess he figures he
always has H6 so he prioritizes
advancing the king
and he's saying you know if you play a
move like Rook h8 he can just play Rook
C6 you know any chance he gets he'll
just take over that file and Go Active
yeah
Rook a seven finesse with the Rooks
tagging play F5
and he does
now don't go Rook G7
and then kill out king F6 or the
discovered check I've seen GM's Wonder
like that before he's preparing the King
march to G3 if things go his way
back to E7
funny thing is Rook G8 here doesn't even
threaten well actually it kind of does
threaten the pawn with Rook G5 King F6
King F4 we can get four yeah and then
you actually win the other Pawn in F5
yeah the thing is if he ever allows
black to play D4 like if he plays a move
like Rook G8 I think Maxine's gonna play
D4 check King F4
um
and then he's got you know Rook E2 or
rookie three to A3 and
quietly mvl might be taking over the
initiative here I mean John might have
played this in two Cavalier fashion he
can go Rook C7 here
among other options and look at this the
King has cut off black sings getting to
C3
and White's the one who has to be
careful now at this point to hold the
draw
but I think he's going to Rook C8 and
Rook Dia this is the classic method
of not allowing progress in this
position
talking D1 is he gonna try
it's a good rook and pawn end game
lesson there Maxine really played some
fantastic defensive moves
oh and he wants more yeah he wants more
he's doing good I mean he can't lose he
could always go back to repeating
oh
I think he's gonna win King F3 there's
King E1 and now there's three four he's
gonna win the pawn
King C2 King C2 to D3 and a bridge no no
no no yeah not quite not quite where is
the win is it Rook C4 is it Rook D4 oh
so you've gotta you've gotta play now
and give up the F Pawn and then you're
just and then it's over then you build
the bridge then you build the bridge
it's over MBL is gonna win how did he
win that whoa end game
that is honestly unreal
that is totally unreal
totally unreal
NEPA was too adventurous with Rook G8 I
think he just needed to keep his Rook
behind that isolated d-pawn once once
Maxine had the space with H4 King on E5
you have to switch to realizing even
though my Rook is active like Black's
position is just good
yeah
no but but I mean
that honestly was just I can't wrap my
head around the fact that he won a draw
I understand but to turn that into a win
is without even a big blunder from nepo
it's not like he made a one single blunt
he got outplayed he flat out got
outplayed
wow okay all right so he goes back
goes back to the pierts
and uh this time Maxim's got a better
position of the opening than last time I
think he can just play C4 and trade on
C4 here
C4
and trade on C4 and try to give black
the bad pawns on the queen side yeah
wow something special C3 that was a
blunder he blunders a piece
he's just flat out blundered a piece
before goodbye oh and we see a reaction
from Maxim he that was really the first
of these in the match
I'd see three allowing B4
wow
and he's not going to resign he's going
to try to come back in this game but I
mean he's down a full piece here
yeah
for no comp
nothing
Queen E4 no
hmm
okay getting their pieces out here yeah
look at that Bishop on A2
rip not doing such a bishop you're
already down a piece now you're
basically down two
yeah and they might very well get
another game I think MBL might simply
resign this
yeah
I guess it's an option for him to run
out the game and go to Bullet
which I actually kind of like I think
that option is should be can seriously
considered maybe that's kind of what
he's doing
yeah
so the fact that he's not resigning here
is is a clear sign that he's
trying to run out the clock but we'll
see
maybe he'll just lose hope and just say
all right enough of this
right that'd be sad if like you can't
even run out the clock
oh yeah
now he can mathematically run out the
clock he's got more time than the match
clock
F4
Queen G4 okay attacking the truck
[Music]
but it's not over because rookie one or
sorry because the rook's hitting the
Knight on D7 so he finds the right yeah
combination of moves those Knights are
still tied up
oh that is a nasty move right there
sinking the net into F3 potentially oh
and queen takes G3 is going to mate him
and this is where we find out if if mvl
wants to make the block two
oh
still fighting taking the other Knight
wait a moment oh 91. Queen takes E1 he
wants queen takes G3 just wants to win
all his Pawns
interesting okay
it's
wow
good stuff from nepo I like it no nepo's
definitely trying to milk out the clock
or MBL rather mdl is yeah
Queenie two still trying
now watch him do all that and then
resign with like two seconds left on the
match clock
Rook takes C5
where's the win
it's made in 11 apparently
really
I I only see an extra night I don't see
any made in 11s I don't either if you if
I try to start checkmating I'll play
something like Knight H5 Queen takes
queen
or I would go Queen takes Queen oh
Knight what attempting truck and then
King takes H3 you lose the Knight but
King G7 was an amazing move
yeah he holds H3 and he holds G2
seven seconds left
yeah that's it The Bishop's going to
resign but that is the last game of the
match time is up
of the three minute portion of course
yeah can't stop Knight G4
fighting still fighting rook's coming in
either today
yeah
this is official That's All She Wrote
all right okay well it also allowed him
to put that blunder three minutes in the
past
yep
it did and he runs out the clock which I
think is totally the right strategy and
he moves to the bullet with a two-point
deficit not the way he wanted to end
David that was a one move peace blender
imagine if he had won this game it would
have been a four point lead but he's got
to put it in the past he's got to
celebrate the fact that he's two points
up with 30 minutes of bullet left to
play it's gonna be an epic finale to the
match isn't it yeah I think I think if I
had black that last game I might have
just like straight up resigned on the
piece hang and got one last game with
white in the three minute portion but
given that it was a blunder in the
opening with white what's the joy in
resigning and then risking another game
with black so he keeps the two-point
lead and um we'll see if he can hang on
to it in the bullet yeah it was totally
the right strategy we will indeed see
whether mvl can hold on to his lead
don't go anywhere we'll be bringing you
more SCC coverage of this epic bullet
segment on the other side of this short
break
International Master Danny wrench Chief
chess officer back again with more chess
terms here for you today we're going to
talk about the past Pawn the past Pawn
must be pushed you hear it said often
and that's because just about every end
game you see that isn't a blowout often
comes down to maybe someone's up one
Pawn or maybe even just the first person
to create a past Pawn is the person who
goes on to win that game we're going to
talk about what the past Pawn is and to
find it for you in today's video let's
do it what is a past Pawn a past Pawn is
a pawn that has no enemy pawns stopping
it from moving forward that means pawns
either on the file in which it resides
or on the adjacent files that would
therefore capture the pawn should it
advance so if a pawn has none of those
things stopping its way then it's time
to push them baby as our boy Yasser
would say and as you hear mentioned on
many broadcasts that you would watch on
chess TV and on that note as we look at
our game examples we like to do this is
taken from Thomas chefsky versus rajaba
here white plays the move V5 xclan which
highlights again it's not how many pawns
you have but who's going to be
threatening to get a queen first after
black takes it white pushes forward with
gusto and because the Rook can't
blockade the pawn due to the light
Square Bishop this game is already over
black is going to have to sacrifice the
bishop for the pawn on B6 and white
would simply be up a minor piece note
that after the first move B5 should a
takes B5 have been played white would
have pushed this pawn and then trap The
Rook on A7 showing the power of the pass
Pawn as with it protecting the bishop
this Rook is completely out of the game
and white would easily go on to win
picking up pawns and just flexing the
rook's muscles over the bishop for the
rest of the game so here we see a
passphawn being used as a weapon to just
cramp down and trap all of your enemy
pieces so this has been another chest
terms video hope you enjoyed it hope
you're enjoying all of them and with
that I will sign off hoping that you
learned something about what a pass Pawn
is and we'll see you around on
shelves.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
not in these positions within the
Tempest the best have come to test their
skills and brave the storm imagine down
to five seconds gonna move wait wait
oh we missed it oh yeah
for some this is familiar ground
this way and move like that
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess
Jagger the moves will be fast oh my God
no 97
tricked at the end the stakes will be
high he just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
I send your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship
and Maxine Michelle Grover contesting a
fascinating match commentating alongside
International Master David Bruce David
30 minutes of bullet to go it's a
two-point lead for mvl and the stakes
could not possibly be higher the prize
pool is pretty mouth-watering
Yeah a hundred thousand dollars total
prize pool for the speed chess
championships main event here
um you can see the breakdowns by by
matches but um in the finals it's a
twenty thousand dollar match it'll be
the same format that everybody's
watching today
you know three hours of Blitz and bullet
it'll be twenty thousand dollars on the
line it's always split between the
winner getting half and then another
half being split by percentage so the
winner
you know walks away minimum with 75 of
the money per round
yeah and and of course the fact that
2000 is split by wooden percentage means
that even if the match is decided
there's still plenty to play for but
this match is anything but decided Jana
has 30 minutes to erase this two-point
lead if the match ends in a tie they
will play a four game one plus one
tiebreaker but we'll cross that bridge
if we get there fasten your speed belts
we are off and Jan has the white pieces
in game one of the bullet and once again
this Knight F3 C4 approach by yawn I
don't like what MPL is doing in the
early going kind of allowing a benoni
yeah he encountered the wrong Bishop if
he knew that this was going to be a
benoni
um so this one should be fantastic for
Yan the bishop can't even get to G7
because D6 is already in agony
and I don't really know
yeah I don't know why allowed B5 though
because it just doesn't even matter by
here by this point I guess
yeah your pieces are so good okay Bishop
H6 trying to prevent it from castling
the downside is that you've traded off
yeah one of your greatest assets he
wants to push E5 potentially and open up
the e-file if black doesn't Castle black
they have to try the very very wild plan
of Kathleen Queens had this game I think
which does exist in the benoni it's very
very rare
but you've seen it before I think it's
time to resort to it yeah instead he
wants to play Rook G8 to G6
and trap the queen yeah how do you I
mean you won't have to work just
straight out for it in order to prevent
that so Knight E2 or something Rook F1
but not moves you you play
you know voluntarily yeah he goes age
four okay so he so you see the chess 960
game where there was a queen on A1 and
Bishop on h8 and uh after like B3 or B4
Magnus played G5 oh G5 I I did see G5
yeah yeah that's that's what this G5
from Maxine reminds me of oh look at
that queenside castling in the benoni oh
email barating back and forth Queen back
to E3 looks like White's much better
here that C3 Pawn is more of a Sitting
Duck than a string I don't know about A4
though
oh now Rook C3 may be coming in
or queen the bullet game and black is up
20 seconds as well
see one Queen
C1 Queen you can just Queen yes but
first Knight D7 to avoid like you know
Rook A6 or Bishop A6 and look at that
move
Force the Queens off the board and now
it's over he's up
he's up and you're already in a
territory where you need to conserve
every second I would resign here like
straight away
down a rook and down a couple points
yeah although no reason for mvl to allow
Knight F5 but still he's totally winning
goes for the base
on D6
should just unpin Rook before Knight C5
still kicking
Rook GA maybe oh no but then that drops
D6 or some definition of kicking I think
King C7 keep bringing the king back
towards the side of the board that has
Pawns
but then white would control the G file
The Rook G2 yeah I'm trying to get his
Knight back around to C6
foreign
yeah I I don't see the point down a rook
this is not going to go anywhere for him
and and he just milked another like
minute and a half off the clock ever
since he lost the rook and now he
resigns
very precise right yeah it's a
three-point lead maybe mdl should have
slowed down a little bit there like oh
you want to play this out down a rook
let me think for one second on each move
I play but he's exactly banging it out
like making a statement about the sports
equivalent in American football when
you're running out the clock it's there
are situations when you don't want to
make the touchdown immediately you want
to wait at the end zone to milk all the
so that the opposing uh Team doesn't get
the ball back they have to force you
into the end zone you're kind of running
the active Force Through the one yard
line exactly oh he dropped a knight it
oh yeah this totally the wheels have
come off completely oh no God is night
trapped in the center
the wheels the wheels have come out that
could be that could be the match if if
Maxine can stay focused and take this
game home cleanly
which she should be able to he's up a
full piece no comp Queen F2 and he's in
a zone right now is Maxine
I don't like Bishop takes C5 but
still still up a piece
so he's either in a zone or he at least
has his extra piece
I would want the knights on the king
side
and he's doing just that and nepo
preventing him though this is obviously
not a situation I would resign in still
chances for black for sure yeah this is
a piece for a pawn the other was like a
rook for for nothing yeah not a zilch
give him the FourSquare for the knights
oh night's coming to E6
that's gonna be nasty
it's over Rook takes C3 Queen takes you
through oh he's even gonna take it with
the queen as well oh and now it's a four
point lead I I suppose this game four
point lead
in the chat in the chat the French must
be going crazy now because now
now it's looking overwhelming it's
looking
well
you're entering like must win territory
at this point 24 minutes is an eternity
in an SCC match that's sure you know
that that's a ton of time they're gonna
play way more than four more games and
all it takes is two wins you think about
it two wins it's a two-play match all of
a sudden Indiana great start in this
game he's much better in a king's Indian
let's see if he can put this one home
I'm just saying he's hit that point
where if he like makes the comeback you
will be going wow what a comeback oh for
sure no he makes a comeback this will be
like among among the best
four point come back and in the last
segment is it's big
oh oh I think this is really bad D6 is
really weak
I would have thrown in Bishop C7 maybe
even now
it goes back to E3 allows F4 with Tempo
like that at all
again he's allowed counter playing he's
gonna throw an exchange at it what is he
doing he's gonna get himself mated
no but he's completely like you he's not
in control of any of these games
he's played terribly this segment thank
you and now it feels free for a bit no
but look at this bishop on H3 Queen on
F3 White's hanging by a thread and mvl
can just bring his Rook to the king side
if he wants that's the simple approach
right also Bishop F6 Bishop G5 looks
good
oh
wow we get a really non-standard what
well that's is that on purpose I think
so yeah he's trying to take B7 promote
his a pawn it makes sense actually
I I don't think it's gonna save him but
oh I think it makes sense the king finds
a good Square so now he's not part of
the problem and now it's up to the
bishop to get its way to E3 you know
Bishop A3 your rook's covering the first
Rank and it's trying to stop Bishop C5
yep so you might have to go directly for
White's King but how do you do that is
the question
oh what what did he need that e-pawn for
well he he used it as a Transit point to
reach A4
but now he's going to drop his Bishop on
f8 Big Move by yawn
okay and now it's just an absolute mess
yeah I still think black has an edge in
a bullet game
[Music]
okay you can take that he's gonna come
around and give a Perpetual at some
point or what no he can't even the
construction stuff that's I don't know
if it was necessary to give up the
exchange I think this is going to be a
draw now
but it was another long game
okay H3 yeah he decides the H Pawn's
already sort of dead he wants to just
get it with the King
mvl sandwiching his King on it oh
wait up Queen
she's so loud
seconds on the table too
I can guarantee you he forgot that it
promoted with check
did mvl yeah oh that's exactly what the
doctor ordered for Napa a miracle win
and the lead is down to three again
wow what a turnaround we just saw in
that game a series of turnarounds
because NEPA was definitely winning out
of the opening
yeah
and then it was totally an mbl's Court
G5 that's not necessary
well he gets a queen trade
it's an 80 win for mvl according to
smarter chess
that's aging pretty well given the way
this game is going
yeah
it looks like he's gonna drop his E5
Pawn for the millionth time yeah it's
like every game that's this is the same
Bishop takes F3 and Knight takes E5 is
like I guess he's got Bishop A4 to save
it
but he didn't
the thing is maybe I missed something
but
yeah no he he decided to give it up
without much of a contest
hey Jan's better again
yeah this is another chance for Yan he
has to win this game I feel like this is
the turning point where this is the
match right here this game
can young pull it together and
capitalize on another advantage
gotta keep our eyes on King F2 Rook D2
so white would love to organize Rook H1
at some point
yep
oh my gosh the pieces are flying and
Giannis so fast so quickly yeah exactly
50 seconds
and he's not slowing down
which is maybe what he has to do maybe
this is how he maybe this is the
infusion that he needs oh my gosh but
mdl is say 500 Rook end games today
yeah exactly he saw the chance to trade
the he even he had the bishop pair which
you might say is some sort of
compensation but he saw oh I can trade
everything off and get another Rook end
game you're never beating me at a rook
end game today
and the way this is going I I think his
streak is going to remain alive and Jan
has even lost some of these rock on
games and Rook A6
lights maybe not worse here either
yeah
oh and yeah oh my God don't lose it
again B takes C4
and now B3 oh he gets connected
passwords Rook D5
okay oh he's gonna lose another one of
these he might it looks really really
dangerous no C6 slow him down with the
Rope oh see why didn't you see six was
winning oh Jan's not even trying to help
to hold this Rook D5 is this this is
better this is Rook d25 just go rookie
cover on c24 anything
Rook C2 or this this is also good enough
just take D2
oh yeah that's it you need to resign
here John
there we go no clue imv I'll let young
keep his Rook but it's still it's
completely winning
King E3
yeah this is this is good technique here
at the end
no way freezing those
King F3 goodbye
nice done
he wins another arguably borderline
losing and Rook end game yeah
again maybe Maxime should just play
slightly slower when he knows he's got
the win and his opponent's not finding
the resignation yep
I would say he's a yeah
what 18 minutes to go
is gonna be about six games and he's got
a four game lead
yeah he's he's about five minutes away
from starting to play the clock
as well as the match
I mean he's he's close to just being
able to bleed the clock in some of these
games yawn has to be perfect from here
on out and he's been anything but
thus far
definitely in the bullet segment 95.
95 chances in the iqp
yeah there's attacking
there's Sparks but is there if only he'd
thrown in rookie one at some point wait
what if black just goes up oh I don't
believe this F takes E5
he's gonna leave it all on the board
here
yeah he's throwing the kitchen sink at
him a knight f4s and him wait Bishop
takes F3 blood on his Queen
maybe you thought was made here
[Music]
Jana's like terminally until right now
oh this is like this is crazy oh no
and he's yelling his head he's not yeah
he's I think he's feeling that the
moment for the match has come and gone
you said it was that end game he needed
to win with black up a pawn where he
again got swindled in the rook and pawn
ending yeah we're out or outplayed I
mean it's not like exactly one Swindle
it's not like
mvl hits him with one little trap it's
just like impeccable Rook end game
technique but the problem has also been
that nepo has been losing those end
games that I mean okay you pull out some
draws understandable but Jan
hasn't even been able to get half points
out of end games that is no business
losing at all so and he's here he's
worse again here so at this point he has
to be perfect there is time for five
more games right it's not mathematically
impossible to make this comeback but the
way Jan is playing right now he's got no
chance and yeah I just saw that shaking
of the head on the last game and it just
felt like here he was getting ready to
give up now he's gonna tag the knights
he's getting totally throttled this game
again Bishop takes C5 and
yeah you know say your prayers
yeah okay uh Queen H4 good good try
wow
hmm oh right because if he's easy if you
traded on C5 and took D7 the Knight
would hang on C3
yep that's a great point
so maybe 94. no he takes D7
but yeah Bishop C3 you're absolutely
right now
that the queen went back he's got rookie
eight Queen E5
queen of six
okay this is mvl's idea he's trying to
go for checkmate
Rook takes F3 but that's just a draw
and frankly that that is not
satisfactory I know for nepo
yeah half of the bullet segment is over
okay still trying wait a second does
white have a Perpetual here
or can Napa pull one a miracle of his
own out of the Hat surely Queen f8 and
then Queen h8 oh
apparently that wasn't the move quick I
thought Queen G2 and queen G5
was the approach but nepo playing very
quickly here trying to lure him in yeah
oh God
yeah that was a pin and now it's a draw
don't go okay he's still trying
yeah it's a draw you're pee three times
and that last part took another minute
off the clock
yeah vaccine looks very very comfortable
here
I mean five point lead
he has not lost okay he's lost one
bullet game and that was by miracle in
that King's Indian
I mean he just
he's totally dominating and it's he's
broken nepo's will to fight I I feel
like I think that's an overused people
talk too much about psychology in
general but I think you can see it here
yeah I mean there was a moment where
nepo shook his head and it just felt
like that was the moment where he
calculated that the match was gone to me
mm-hmm
was that after he lost that Rook end
game you think yep
for sure
still trying yeah but mvl is so solid
here
yeah this is a super position tab at
this point this kind of position for
black because this is like a 100 move
game if white wants to to Win It
yeah very astute opening choice to play
a Karo Khan as you said you know that
force is a long game
and mvl flat out better here nepo is
doing a whole lot of head shaking right
now
and then some lashing out
yeah I mean you've got to try but
that ain't gonna cut it
yeah actually so solid I mean it's like
it's just fundamentally you forgot all
the squares you need for your pieces
if King f8 rookie six if you try to
evacuate
so yeah just cut them off from cut them
off from the center you know go for Rook
D1 Knight H5 Maybe
is is it is a try it just takes he says
go grab my pot I don't care I've got E7
yeah
I mean you can't play rookie four
because of Rook D1
if you trade off here and oh oh he's
even calculated he didn't even take oh
what a move and now he's up by six okay
now the match is totally okay and I have
an apple going 1p6
Surefire oh what does he do okay
he allowed C3 with Tempo yeah
okay he's totally on the Tilt train now
yeah well I mean there comes a point
where you know
you know your competitor you're playing
to win a match you don't win the match
like it's hard to stay motivated I know
that every bullet game is worth at least
a hundred dollars but it's still like
you're not there to make 100 that you're
there to win a match there was an
instantly winning tactic that was missed
there I think white could have taken on
G5
okay weird I don't know what's going on
in this game but
whatever it is it's very strange the
king comes rushing out yeah King H2
but the way NEPA was playing mvl's gonna
win like literally every position
G5
I think is his idea
oh Bishop B5
man oh man when black played D5 it was
tempting to retreat the Knight and leave
all the black pieces stuck on the queen
side oh definitely
flying the flag
he's trying to keep the king side closed
off but
I don't know if that's he's gonna be
successful
I'm shocked at the way this bullet
segment has gone this has just been
totally one-sided thus far
hypothetically 10 and a half minutes to
go there is enough time I think
for five games
with 40 seconds on the clock he totally
should have milked that clock down I
think he's just so sure he's gonna win
the match he feels it doesn't matter
the move there's Queen B6 by the way
yeah refuting the opening variation yeah
but instead he goes Queen A5 okay does
94 still work here
seems to
yeah this has been known since the Stone
Age but somehow
all right the handshake to get a real
position yeah all right all right enough
Shenanigans let's get a real end game
okay Yana's a minute and 12 seconds yeah
I feel literally
I feel like mdl shouldn't get like
sucked into like absolute just like play
the game in 10 seconds kind of level
yeah but look at this night before it's
coming okay okay but yeah that's just I
mean he played this game at a lot of
1600 level because he wasn't thinking he
has over a minute on his clock I'm so
glad you said that and not me I did I
feel great but I didn't want to be the
one to say it I I normally never permit
myself phrases like this but I think the
chat can like it kind of speaks for its
game kind of speaks for itself
and even Jan would agree I think in this
case
yeah no I mean usually these players
will be the harshest critics of
themselves you know like they'll play a
game with like two inaccuracies and say
like I could like at 1200 yeah more like
a twice 650 but okay I I say that all
the time on Street like I'm playing like
a 1300 like no you're not you know shush
yeah but in this case I mean with this
game I mean allowing that that opening
trap
yeah he's trying to work his way out of
it
now nepo has come to the board
the funny thing is MBL could repeat here
and you probably wouldn't mind that
he's not going to
yeah I mean what what would you tell
yourself if you're in a situation like
this and the match is lost like you how
do you play out the last couple moves
what's the best you can get out of the
game at that point cute move by by and
be all there well I would just say
listen there's there's eight minutes to
go it's
you know it's not like you're on an 11
hour flight you're you know the torture
is limited so you might as well try to
finish with a pleasant taste in your
mouth
um and right now that's not happening
Jan is digging himself further and
further into the hole now it's just
becoming a flat out lopsided match and
the score doesn't tell the story of the
match I mean it's been a close match all
throughout
yeah
the only time that I've ever been in
these matches I lost both of them by
lopsided scores like this but I came
into the matches expecting to lose so
having a losing score didn't change my
approach it was just to try and play an
occasional good game so it wasn't wasn't
like an issue you played Bartholomew in
one of those matches right I lost to
Bartholomew badly in one match and uh
yeah I lost a second match as well also
badly yeah he's a nightmare opponent
though
he's in Charlotte right now actually so
I think I'll be hanging out with him
tonight nice Health permitting
[Music]
slightly unpleasant for Jan again
set some kind of a knight c5f4 trap
B3 but now we're looking one and he wins
C3 loses C5 C5
okay I'm Bill's not losing this one
either I think
[Music]
um
no maybe he is both players have over 50
seconds which is nuts
right they could play 500 games like
this yeah and Beyond these offers a draw
I agree it's drawn
[Music]
let's see with what amount of time John
ends this okay E3 pre-move
okay he's super tilted
yeah you said that Maxine was fast but I
mean John is playing like hyper bullet
107 I mean faster than hyperbole I mean
he's just playing Ultra bullet and he's
losing every game I mean look at this
it's a desires catastrophic E4 Knight T4
see she's got that stuff and knights
coming to F3 and it's over he's just
gonna take it on F3 so npl says no this
is elementary school right structure
keep the pawn structure yeah Knight's
just chilling on C2 I can have a vast
menu of Rooks to capture here yeah crook
B8
okay he waited until NEPA with one of
his Rooks the other one was trapped
but he finally decided to take it
okay and the King commits suicide too
yeah another game goes into the toilet
for yawn Bishop E1 his idea is to meet
Bishop takes D5 with Knight takes people
actually a quality move right there
okay
I would try to keep the Queens if I were
mvl but he's also up in exchange so
why not
five minutes to go
and honestly this match could not end
soon enough for nepo
yeah he's ready he's ready I've been in
that situation before too where I was
like okay I'm done with this oh he just
made it H3 broke other Rook comes to
Jesus Rook over oh oh Rook G4
chef's kiss giving us something to it
here
this is beautiful oh look what is Napa
doing this is just losing out of the
opening
oh he's gonna resign 95. wait
wait a minute this this has to be just
flat out lost I think Knight T5 was
better
oh man this is sad
and you you get it from John's
perspective like he was expecting to win
this match so like you said David it's
all about your mentality right I mean if
you're expecting to win by a wide margin
and you find yourself getting thrashed
you just it's just so hard to adjust
okay I'm gonna play my best anyway yeah
oh my God
cleaning them up
to all sorts of puns here you could even
take on F7 and he probably will
maybe even a first yeah
she works for a queen
bringing the king out not what I
expected
but not enough pieces I think for black
to punish him yeah
wow
and it happens I mean it's it's just all
mvl this match I mean really quality
chess all all around
you know in all formats
or for mvl but let's see how he finishes
it off he had a great day today
just showing that it's not not a
coincidence that he got into the finals
of the SEC
it never is storm clouds gathering for
the black king yeah wants to play F6
meanwhile whites King is safer than ever
for the time being at least even five
attacking the queen from the side that
was funny
King F4 Queen F2
King G5 Queen G3 and then you win the
other Rook
hard to say what happens there he just
goes back no need to risk
mm-hmm at this point it's obviously
mathematically over seven games in two
minutes would be a little bit difficult
oh
I think you can push just e67
yeah you can also go back to H4 with the
rook and uh it's pretty powerful too
I don't understand why I didn't play E6
yeah he's trying for Queen C6 or B7 and
some checkmates
on F3 or H3 oh now it's a game again
probably a professional attack
yeah just the room for the perpetual
46 seconds on the clock
eeks out a draw
this is well the way they've been
playing probably not the last game of
the match probably will have two more
yeah
maybe try to set a record for most games
played I mean
yeah this is up there for sure
another delightful position at an
opening for Yan yikes
he drives the pawn into E3 on takes it
though what is the follow-up yeah
yeah had the bishop taken there was
Knight G4
okay now Knight's on me
that was a terrible move by Yan
it's very funny hearing you say that
allowing Bishop D4 Knight F6
yeah I'm going after him in this in this
bullet segment yeah now Queen yeah
that's pretty good taking zero Away From
Evil who has who has played at just an
amazing match no like literally no
question about that at all E3 and queen
takes D5 I think is good enough for the
for the dub
right or maybe Queen G5 depending where
black goes where where Jan goes
oh and I we're gonna have another two
Rooks for the queen position probably
Queenie five Bishop C3 he just goes
simple yeah
this is gonna be the last game of the
match
oh yeah
finally I gotta say for you finally
Mr Napo it was entertaining up to a
point but once it's no fun for yawn it's
no fun for me either you know like I
need everybody to be having fun to
really enjoy myself at this point for
sure
yeah mvl's gonna take this one by a wide
margin
he traps the queen did you see that that
was pretty scary yeah
yeah the queen is arrested now you can
maybe just push the queen side puns and
try to create a passer let's go P5 oh
three man he wins the last game as well
some cool moves everybody else finishes
with the largest lead of the match at
eight he smashes nepo in the bullet Five
Point win in the bullet segment alone
tack on two more from the previous two
segments
and he wins by seven by seven points
what a match David I mean all credit to
to mvl I mean he he really defied
expectations I mean the community seemed
just a custom to nepo's Excellence in
the last months and years but not today
but not today I mean he started off well
but I think that uh MPL gave him like
more resistance that he was prepared for
today
um those those rook and pawn egg games
that he saved I mean some really dodgy
situations
and on Maxine was just was just really
really really strong today
yeah he was he was strong in all-time
controls
he was well prepared in the opening he
was fast and really that was one of the
biggest X factors was how would MBL
handle time pressure he did all of it
super well and he will explain more
about his approach and his mentality
when we interview him after a short
break so ladies and gentlemen we review
the final score here uh it's it's a big
score indeed he wins the Bullet by six
points I apologize so yeah he wins the
overall match by eight points and Maxima
sheligra the Frenchman with three names
will be joining us for an interview we
want to remind you that you should
publicize and write out your questions
for mvl in the chat we will have some
featured questions from the chat we
can't promise to to let everybody ask a
question but a couple of the best ones
we will most certainly ask mvl in the
interview so spam the chat with your
good questions and we will have Maxime
in the studio for an interview on the
other side of this break we'll be right
back
foreign
ER Danny wrench Chief chess officer back
again with more chess terms here for you
today we're going to talk about the past
Pawn the past Pawn must be pushed you
hear it said often and that's because
just about every end game you see that
isn't a blowout often comes down to
maybe someone's up one Pawn or maybe
even just the first person to create a
past Pawn is the person who goes on to
win that game we're going to talk about
what the past Pawn is and to find it for
you in today's video let's do it what is
a past Pawn a past Pawn is a pawn that
has no enemy pawns stopping it from
moving forward that means pawns either
on the file in which it resides or on
the adjacent files that would therefore
capture the pawn should it advance so if
a pawn has none of those things stopping
its way then it's time to push them baby
as our boy Yasser would say it as you
hear mentioned on many broadcasts that
you would watch on chess TV and on that
note as we look at our game examples we
like to do this is taken from Thomas
chefsky versus rajaba here white plays
the move B5 5x Glam which highlights
again it's not how many pawns you have
but who's going to be threatening to get
a queen first after black takes it white
pushes forward with gusto and because
the Rook can't blockade the pawn due to
the light Square Bishop this game is
already over black is going to have to
sacrifice the bishop for the pawn on B6
and white would simply be up a minor
piece note that after the first move B5
should a takes B5 have been played white
would have pushed this pawn and then
trap The Rook on A7 showing the power of
the pass Pawn as with it protecting the
bishop this Rook is completely out of
the game and white would easily go on to
win picking up pawns and just flexing
the rook's muscles over the bishop for
the rest of the game so here we see a
passport being used as a weapon to just
cramp down and trap all of your enemy
pieces so this has been another chest
terms video hope you enjoyed it hope
you're enjoying all of them and with
that I will sign off hoping that you
learned something about what a pass Pawn
is and we'll see you around on chess.com
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Championship the winner of today's epic
SEC match is here in the studio we
welcome Grandmaster Maxima Sheila grav
Maxim thank you for joining us let's
start uh with an overview question can
you share your thoughts about the match
overall how you played and when you felt
like you had full control of the match
um it's hard to say because we like I
feel like I generally played quite well
even maybe very well
uh but I had a lot of absences and like
um
uh blunders in one move
um that's not really usual
especially because uh on the other end I
was calculating the online quite sharply
generally
at good positions after the opening but
sometimes played uh for the clock
a bit too much I would say in the five
plus one and three plus one and
sometimes I managed to
[Music]
uh to actually like
uh turn things around and uh you know
find some good tactics or sometimes in
the end games uh just out playing
because he was playing so fast
and so it was you know
and you know we each other moment and
then I went with plus two entering the
Buddha section and there I think uh
young just went on unticked uh after the
first game
which I really shouldn't have won I
guess uh I don't really remember but
then I won it and after that he
he won percent more
so so when you went into the bullet
portion with two extra points what was
kind of your your feeling or attitude at
that point
well the thing is uh I felt I was
playing too slow
uh in the other two sections to keep uh
on that rhythm in the OnePlus One but
luckily I had been playing lots of
bullets uh in the last few days
so that helped me a lot you know to to
find immediately a good rhythm of play
and uh I think that went uh really
pretty well
uh I was actually going to ask you about
that Maxime rumor has it that you played
a bullet match with alireza yesterday
who were some of your opponents in the
last couple of days and how much of a
role do you think that played in in your
success uh in this match
yeah not only yesterday but the day
before and uh but yesterday was a bit
tough because it was 30 seconds and I
don't just don't have the mouse feet to
and you know to challenge him in 30
seconds in one minute I can put up a
serious fight at least
so I was pretty confident that you know
on a good day in bullet
I don't feel too bad about my chances
against uh most of the players uh out
here maybe
and then and then a very good day
I'm not afraid of anyone basically
yeah now if I could ask you something
about openings
um when when he pulled out the modern
defense it felt like he got good
positions with black in two games with
the modern defense in the three-minute
portion does does that concern you like
how do you feel when an opening is going
for you or against you does that how how
do you adjust or deal with that feeling
I just fell back to to not punish uh
punish him and on the country like uh
you know Play Summer to to passive to
slowly and uh but actually rendering a
piece in one in the last game of
of the three plus one sections so then I
realized I should just uh you know
find some ways to finish the game and go
into the OnePlus One because that if I
had another one of these three plus one
I would have gone on tip that to this
one
um so this was you know a good moment
for me and then
um
yeah I think for what it was
trying this uh this video press I mean
first Berlin quite a lot and then
Marshall
uh but I thought that was a wrong choice
because in
like he's very well acquainted with a
petrof and of course I had prepared
something but in the SRI Lopez I just
could play anything I want and I like I
I have done that for a living play
against the Berlin
yeah so you're comfortable against the
Berlin
well Maxime before we let you go we have
a couple of featured chat questions uh
first one something I was curious about
myself we have to ask you whether you're
following the World Cup
uh and if so how how closely
and uh I guess who you're rooting for is
pretty much an empty question but I
still have to ask it
well let's uh we like I've been
following a bit more lately in the last
few days uh
I actually watched the last match of
friends at daddy with us place
um in Paris
um so of course I'm looking for friends
but if not I would very much like to see
Messi win the World Cup
cool
cool yeah I have a question which is
like outside of Chess right now what
would be like your greatest passion or
Joy or Hobby
I have a few
uh I mean I definitely
collect two things I would do as soon as
I would type from chess luckily I mean
hopefully that is a few years away at
the very least
um so I would like to you know extend a
bit my knowledge in mathematics because
uh it's been a while since I've
I went to to UNI like it's been 12 or 13
years it's uh a bit frightening so
probably
uh catch up a bit on that and uh
and maybe do some I think because I feel
very comfortable in the mountains so
like some
maybe go for the Ops first and then
maybe maybe more depending on how I feel
about that and how I feel you know by
the time I turn 40 or 45 or whatever
mm-hmm all right well mvl final question
before I let you go what's next uh on
your tournament schedule where can we
see you compete next
well first you can see me competing uh
in the quarter finals of speeches
championship
[Laughter]
uh but then uh
I'll be different
types already
in inarmaty so what were a few templates
awesome excellent we very very much look
forward to seeing you there I see
Michelle agrov congratulations on the
win uh we'll let you rest thanks for
joining us thank you yeah thank you bye
all right that's all she wrote David
what a match I mean the SEC is off to
such a great start mvl with the most
lopsided win today and you wouldn't
think that it would come in this match
you just never know with the SEC do you
yeah at first when I wanted to uh make a
bold prediction I saw it was 78 for yawn
in the brackets I thought my bold
prediction would be that MBL will lose
by one point instead of three and I said
no scratch that I'm going to predict
that mdl wins by one point and I thought
that was incredibly bold to predict for
him to win it and then he just racked up
the score there
she really did it was it was an amazing
display and and we saw in BL and how
composed he is how well prepared he was
uh and and he prepared through all the
bullet matches which undoubtedly helped
him in in that final segment it was so
fun to watch this match
and uh mvl always a great interview you
know always always fun to ask him he's
uh always willing to share his thoughts
yeah wow and I think he showed like a
really really really high level of form
today so going forward he said the next
place to see him is going to be the
quarterfinals that's going to be a tall
tall order and a steep challenge for uh
either Wesley so or no dear Beck Abdul
sadarov
um because I think Maxine was playing a
really great level today
if he keeps his form I honestly think he
can really go all the way the Wesley
outer back match is going to be epic
um Carlson gukash of course as well the
winner facing Fabby
and the next match is going to be
uh Lavon aronians contest against
Dimitri on Drake and pretty sure that
that's coming your way on Wednesday this
coming Wednesday
at 10 A.M Pacific time so it's going to
be an awesome match but that is another
one in the books ladies and gentlemen
time has come for us to start wrapping
up David I'll pass it on to you for uh
your final thoughts before I close off
the show yeah I mean there's one other
thing coming up in addition to the match
on Wednesday we've got the 2022 fide
women's candidates tournament pool B
begins tomorrow
um 6 a.m Pacific Time on chess.com and
as you can see we'll have Llano who's in
top form right now gloriachikina
kostenyuk and tan Jong Yi
um they will be contesting uh uh a pair
of matches and then the winners will
also be playing a match
I believe
um over the next two weeks and so check
out all the coverage of that here on
chess.com as they inch towards the
Women's Championship title match
fantastic well the women's candidates
coming your way soon the next SEC match
is on Wednesday but for now ladies and
gentlemen this has been so much fun
David always a pleasure commentating
with you
the SCC continues Wednesday at 10 A.M
Pacific with Lavon against undraken but
for now we wish everyone a fantastic
rest of your Monday and for our entire
awesome team at chess.com and
international Master David Bruce I'm
Grandmaster Daniel narditski saying
goodbye from the round of 16 here at the
speed Chess Championship we will see you
on Wednesday thanks everybody
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]